This episode of Your Mom's house is
brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that
provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
[inaudible] saw
Christina.
Well, I guess it's official.
We're finally here inside studio.
Jean. I'm Tom Cigarette. She's
Christina p big tits ski.
That's rude.
And we did it.
We were in the studio
and let's get physical.
Let's get physical making a podcast.
Oh my gosh. Can you believe Eddie?
What do you think of this? That's amazing.
It's amazing. We'll get into it. Okay,
let's go through these dates. It's
official man. Tommy Salaams. Yep.
All right.
Hmm.
Should I just start talking now?
Okay, here we go. All right guys,
just so you know,
January 10 comedy store main room,
we're almost sold out. Uh, your queen
jeans is going to be headlining,
but guess who's added to the lineup?
Thompson Guerra,
Josh Potter has just agreed to do the
show and so many others is going to be a
fantastic night. There's just a handful of
tickets. Scoop them up. If you're in La,
January 31st 31st or February 2nd.
Denver, Colorado comedy works.
February 23rd West Syndrome Springs,
Oklahoma, the Cherokee casino.
February 28th through March 2nd, Madison,
Wisconsin at the comedy club on state.
And then April four through six,
many apple tits at acme.
May 10th and 11th, Tempe,
the Improv. June 23rd,
22nd Washington Dick come as a dick.
Come Improv.
Christina p online for
tickets. Thank you. All right.
Uh, this weekend I'm in San Diego. I
have three shows at the Balboa theatre,
the 11th and the early show
on the 12th or sold out.
But um,
the late show still has
probably some singles. Um,
so I would try to get those.
If you are in San Diego,
let's see. Oklahoma City,
um, it's all sold out.
There are late show tickets for
the Houston show at the, uh,
revention music center. Is
that how you say it? Yeah,
we're a bunch of music center.
Those steps. That is a, the 25th,
January 25th and then the 26 is sold out,
but we added a show the 27th.
There are a few tickets left there.
If you want to go, that's at the
majestic. Go to Tom skirt.com.
Click on the tour page
and get tickets there.
All right. Oh my God. Well, look
at the, Oh my God. Oh my God.
Oh my God.
It's gonna.
It's,
it's about to go down.
We are in the new studio,
our genes.
We're in studio jeans. Um, there's so much
to talk about, so much to get into. Yeah.
But as always, we have to get
the show off to the right start.
Let's kick things off in the new
studio with an all new clip and,
uh, we'll, we'll, we'll cover everything.
I can't wait. Are you ready? I'm ready.
Let's do it. Gene knew Monica. Yeah.
All y'all beautiful
women. You feel me? This,
let me eat you one term.
This,
let me eat your one time and you're
going to, I guarantee you you're gonna,
you're gonna ask me to stick
to your house. You go to
sleep for three days. My BB,
no,
Christina.
Hello.
Look at this here. Look at this.
I know. See that it says next.
Dot. Brown tog et that it's my
lipsticks and the lady. Well,
um, it's official. It is official.
And your mom's house is continuing to
enlighten the audience with these hard to
find men and they're irresistible offers.
I thought this is the new art Kelly show.
Everybody who is watching
this is it, I guess you've never seen
our Kelly before. So that's him. Yeah,
he's aged a little. Just a little
bit. Yeah. Still talking about sex,
but going the grind in and,
yeah.
You know what's amazing is that like
the perverts don't age out. You know,
you're like these surely there's
a time where you're like,
I'm too old for boners.
I would think that, yeah.
Around 10 years younger than
him. Yeah. You'd be like, oh,
stop offering the eat girls in videos.
Or at least the point in your life when
you put the chain on your bifocals,
which is what he's done.
Like when you've got a rope around your
neck to keep the glasses on your eyes,
the eyes always tell the story.
And I think doctor drew would maybe say,
something's going on in the eyes here.
What do you think? I Dunno. It just,
it's not a normal gays,
you know?
That's not well. And, um,
yeah and I liked the way he phrases it.
Can we see that? Um, just the whole,
cause it's a whole nice offer.
Oh y'all beautiful wind.
That's nice. You feel this?
Let me eat you one term.
This let me eat your one time and you're
going to, I guarantee you you're gonna,
you're gonna ask me to stick
to your house. You got your,
you got to sleep for three days.
My beat
did the, the European [inaudible] then
that's when his accident pop too. Yeah.
The 30 days be blue. This but it might
be from the islands. Jamaica. Yeah.
Well I'll tell you, this has some of
the makings of a great way. Mh Video.
He tried to ruin the show with that.
God dammit. The little dust in here.
Jesus Christ. God Damn. Ah, well
number one, let's go through it.
Um, framing, how are we doing? Are Pretty
terrible framing but I've seen worse.
But yeah, I mean he would
make, he would make the cut.
Now I'm embarrassed to say this
man has a shirt on absolutely
revolting that he dared
to send him his video.
However there is a hole and a hole and
he makes up for it with a Bandana on his
head. The Bandanas. Weird Bandana
gets you extra points. Sure.
He doesn't have all his teeth.
There's a couple of gold ones,
so that's pretty cool.
Yeah, that's perfect.
And the fact that he chose the goal is
kind of, it's, it's switches things up,
but subject matter is a one point.
That's how he, that's how when you get,
when you, when you open
like that, it's fantastic.
And also another checklist is
location. Location, location. Yes.
And this one, he chose his front lawn,
which is bold. It's an outdoor video.
Neighbors. Sure. Kids are playing. Yeah.
It's what you want from somebody
that is living in your neighborhood.
Which by the way, I don't even know
that he lives in this neighborhood.
He might not, I don't think it's his
yard because he and his offer, he's like,
if you let me eat you,
you, you'll be like stay.
And I think he's like basically off he's
bay. This is basically a petition to,
can I sleep at someone's house? You think
so? I think so. And the trade off is,
I'm really good at eating so we could
match him up actually with like get Elise.
Nikki, try it out. Yeah, this is his,
this is the try it out. Try it out.
Guy Was a beautiful woman. No, we'll
try it again once a black guys. Yeah,
but I had a jail. I don't think
that tried out. Guy Would,
I don't think this guy would enjoy,
he might do the beat me like you
know piss on me. Beat me. Yeah.
He might try it out but he's not going
to eat him. What else does he say?
He says some more stuff. No thanks. He
said some other things all done. No.
Next to push. No Bush. Do you
need to see more like we got it.
No we didn't
guess what more are you sure
you would time eat enough?
I tell you they got a man up a whoa. I
could cook for you. Clean up your house,
visit when you come home baby.
You just got a job in jumping
to toe with all of them.
Bubbles.
Okay,
so I'm definitely on point.
He is looking for a place to stay.
You're right.
How did you know that he needs
housing and he's not a dick.
I'm going to cook. Right? I'm going to
clean and I'm going to, he's basically,
this is leading up to,
I'm guessing I'll eat you
right after that bubble bath,
but he's saying be cleaned for me to do
that and that's always a big issue is
vaginal cleanliness to these guys. These
guys are very picky about these guys.
Meaning meaning every guy that puts
out the cool car irrational. Yeah,
I got you. Okay. But they don't seem
to care about hygiene in themselves,
but it's very important that she
have hygiene, which is ironic.
I first of all the two fees you could
be missing to have your front too.
It's always unique weight,
but he's,
if you go back a little
more, yeah, I know.
I saw for there's oof can
really see it clearly.
There I go.
Dammit.
And you can highlight the missing two
fees because the one next to the missing
is gold. So you're like, hey, that's
gold. Oh Hey, there's no tooth. Well,
that's the thing is that
he sprung for the gold.
Why not spring for like the
real, the veneer, you know
what I mean? Or the implant.
Maybe he's living his best
life and goes, he's not like,
I don't need all these teeth. I see one
or two people having a good enough life.
I'm living my good enough.
I,
oh need real chief is,
I'm living in. Okay. Like,
yeah, Jean Jean, it's, I can't
believe it's actually here. Okay.
What it's finally happening
at the top of the pad,
if you can see behind us, we are in
studio gene. We're proud of ourselves.
[inaudible] House. Yeah. You
look, we discussed the motif.
It is steak house meets the People's
Court. Yeah. We want it to be official.
Yeah, that is true. It's masterpiece
theater steakhouse and the People's Court,
this is a long time coming.
I mean the,
the dream of it is longer. The
reality of it is, you know,
you were super pregnant.
I went out and started looking at spaces
right in around June. Yeah. All right,
so that's six months ago. And
then found this place. I think I,
I I to say I didn't sign a lease until,
I think it was September,
October it, Elise, Nikki, yeah. I got
to listen to key in September, October.
And then, um, what happened next? Oh,
I had a guy who was going to do
everything. Oh, build the sets,
do the tech,
do everything.
And like the day after I signed the lease,
so like now I'm committed and
I walked. He was like, yeah,
it's not really gonna work out for me.
I was like, what? Totally screwed us.
I remember I was very pregnant.
It's floating around in our pool,
trying to keep cool in the
middle of summer. And you're
like, this guy just, uh,
just got pulled out. And you know,
who really helped really helped me.
The first guy I called with was Ethan
Klein. It's right, um, you know,
Ethan Hilo from age three.
And I was like,
cause I know he knows a lot about
production and sets. And I was like, dude,
can you,
and he hooked it up.
He put me in touch with Tj more
who built this set and then,
uh, Nadave or our very own bird,
a little behind in the nests are,
yeah. He, um, became very involved.
And then we got, you know,
the technical aspect going, um, pod or
help with a lot of production stuff.
And then we hired Mel and this great
lighting crew and then, I don't know,
it all came together. And then after
all this was set up, we were like, oh,
it's not soundproofed enough in here.
So then we had to hire top
tier soundproof [inaudible],
which we are actually halfway through it.
So I don't even know how this,
I hope this sounds good to you guys.
It'll sound even better next week when
they're completed with it, but it's, uh,
it's been a whole, well,
I will say, I mean, look,
we used to film the show next to our
son's bedroom when he was sleeping as a
baby. So we've done the show in many
different locations. Pilati studios was,
that was like six. Yeah, I think the
thing, this is still pretty good now.
This is still great. It's
still great, but you know,
saying I would like to point out some
old school features just so some of you I
know don't like change. My therapist
tells me I'm not good with change.
There's a lot of stuff
from the old studio.
If you'll notice we have our dog mask,
our mascot GG Allen is here.
I got Webster behind me.
City connection,
a Fifo with all the dog tits. Yeah. Yeah.
Of course.
Blue Band might.
One of my favorites fan submitted things
of me as the Virgin Mary water bottles
of water, toilets, all the stuff you
know and love and behind me, right?
The dog pup play, the terrifying
pup play. Who's your owner?
But last time I came out as poly.
Yeah.
And I'm proud to say I'm bisexual,
but also I'm so excited.
You're ready.
I'm ready for this big announcement.
Caddying kibble
when other sounds
chips in a bowl
vegging out. Now I'm
building up. I'm ready.
Go for it guys.
After many years of talk,
I'm proud to announce,
behold the fart Mike.
It's finally here. Wow. We've been
talking about this for so long.
We really have been. And I have to
say so many wasted far it's okay
but I want to thank blue band and Josh
pawn or everybody for making this fart.
Mike Possible.
I don't think this audience understands
the level of importance she put on this
for today because I was more worried
about you know these monitors working and
sound drops and you know those types
of technical problems and Christina was
like if this fucking
fart and Mike isn't here,
why did we even build the studio?
I agree cause I know how important
the Farc Mike is tour listeners,
I feel like they've been demanding it
for years and if we're going to spend all
this money and time building a studio,
this to me is the most important thing.
We should also point out that yes,
right now it just looks like
an extra mic laying around.
We're going to dress it up. Okay.
It's going to have its own arm,
couldn't have the label,
are going to note for today for
episode one it's merely a Mike,
but this will soon have the appearance
of of special of royalty basis.
This is really going to be something
else and hopefully we will on it's on the
arm, will be able to pass it over to the
guests and share it with one another.
So I was a little upset
because we usually,
we don't record the
show this early usually,
but we woke up this morning and
Tom had such great fart at home.
I had a really, I took a
disgusting shit last night. Yeah,
I had,
well I had an Omelet for dinner and
then I watched the national championship
game, uh, and uh, Bart and Arie came over.
So last year we went to,
at this time they came over to the house.
I don't drink normally,
I'm boozing it up cause I got this booze
bag friend over and you know what I
mean?
And he was like pouring scotch to
the rim of a glass. I was like,
what are you doing man?
So anyways,
that's sitting in my stomach and I had
to take a dump at like midnight. Really?
Where did you shit in our master and our
bedroom downstairs. Downstairs. Oh Wow.
Bold. I know. And then I,
um, got up this morning,
well you woke me up to be fair with the
fart and then I had a few and then I was
like, Ooh, this is not going to be,
but it upset me that we didn't
have the Fart Mike at home. Oh,
it upset me that we waited
so late to do this show.
We should have been doing this show
at six 30 in the morning. You know, I,
sorry guys. That's the new call time.
That's when it starts to happen.
So you're throwing money out the window.
It's true.
That could have been on Fort Mike.
It's very true.
So the good news is we had a lot of
bean dip while you're watching the game.
I'm hoping that there's still
some farts in me from last night.
We stopped at Starbucks, so let's
hope that all that is going to create,
I want to make a point here.
This is a, an amazing studio.
This, yeah. Um, you know, we're going
to do, by the way, a behind the scenes,
um, tour of everything, right?
[inaudible] band and we'll, we'll,
we'll show everybody all the
ins and outs like to what level?
Everything was built out. This is
better audio. It's better video.
It's all that stuff.
But it's still your mom's house.
And one of our listeners actually made a,
um,
a quick, your mom's house. Super
Cut. Do you know who built it? Uh,
Caleb is a Caleb. I Dunno. I'm asking
God. No, I forgot. I forgot to look it up.
Okay. All right. It's all very cold in
here. I know you're happy about that.
I'm happy about that. But uh, can we take
a look at this? Uh, this is pretty cool.
What he built here.
All right.
Mona. Julia woke up so
morning just wanting to say,
can I change the locks on your doors?
You want to move in? You come move here.
Please don't ever go back in the past.
I know,
cause I need to be fucked a lot man.
And I understand when having
sex with a gun in the ass hole.
Disgusting is nothing compares
to in front of jail, homeless,
not take fucking 30
Benadryl want at night.
I'll make you feel like a woman or man
after you experienced an enormous amount,
even know who your ex boyfriend is just
home, Ya know? You know what I'm saying?
Let's go pull a tribe
and a curse,
but I want to fuck you pretty bad
to get blowjobs and try it out.
You're gorgeous. Let's go have some
fun and let's get physical. Fuck me.
I have a good day,
mother fucker.
Find out who made that.
That was fantastic.
Those are all the gentlemen I
forgot about speed and you can add,
let me eat you mix. But uh,
I forgot about how Ben is real
guides sometimes in a bad mood.
He's irate. He when, when he goes
have a good day, mother fucker.
He's alone.
Yeah. Yeah. That's good. Yeah.
Whoever made that good job.
Yeah.
Really sorry.
I had to see them all together. Like
that was kind of jarring all scumbags,
you know, celebrate it on this show.
Yeah, that's true. Right? It's like,
it's a lot really crazy.
It is a lot. It's um,
it's looking,
they're all montage together like that.
I think it's fair to say, I mean, I
don't want to be like too arrogant,
but when you see something like that,
we've kind of changed the world. You know?
In a lot of ways,
giving people a platform to
shine that would otherwise just
some universe like we've actually
helped these guys get. Yeah. Like what
if someone right now I was like, yeah,
that like some woman is like, God,
those guys sound hot. That's true. That'd
be Rad. Okay. That probably is true.
Probably true. Oh by the
way, got to say this.
So you guys know our good friends at
Saatva have always been a huge supporters
of ours,
of the show.
I talked to them about this and they're
onboard and I think it's so awesome that
this is going to be a reality.
So to celebrate the fact that we're
in this new space in the new studio,
Saatva is going to give away a two
mattresses to listeners for free.
One site for one loom
and leaf memory phones.
Here's how you win the free mattress.
I think some people
will have fun with this.
Send us a video no longer than 30 seconds
of why you should get one of the free
mattresses. You can show us your
current mattress, you can describe it,
you can just give us a reason.
And if it's funny and creative,
uh, we will vote in house.
We'll showcase some of them, but
send it to our email, which is, uh,
your mom's podcast@gmail.com and
put Saatva in the subject line.
S a te Va a once again,
or if there's,
if there's a, if I could say it
without a belt, just for the listener.
It's a fun guys in the subject lines,
creative energy,
s a t v a in the subject line and send
it again less than 30 seconds and win a
free awesome mattress.
It's going to be either the loom and leaf
memory foam or the actual sock Saatva
luxury firm. They're fantastic.
And I want to thank Sam for,
for doing that very much.
Um,
can I tell you this credit what early
adapters they were to podcasting
advertising. They were our first
sponsor of your mom's house.
And Kudos to them for being so forward
thinking. They were awesome. Yeah.
I mean they still are, but yeah, that
was really cool when they got, um, uh,
got involved with this a while back.
We have to talk about, by the way,
before we move further along that,
uh,
over the weekend or before the weekend,
I think before the holiday week,
during our off week so to speak,
uh,
Louie had a set that was leaked,
created this in the sane backlash
in the comedy and the chaos.
Why is it disturbed me on so many
levels? I mean I'm, I'm serious.
What, what was the worst? What was
disturbing for you? Okay. First of all,
the idea that,
I mean especially when when people in
comedy who know better act like they don't
is what it, what bothered me is
that this is clearly a workout,
right?
Like the Guy Theater,
it's like at a club in long island that's
in governors and long gun and he does
like a 45 minute set.
It's probably his 15th,
12th to 15th time on stage.
Since being offstage for like 10 months.
And this is part of the process
of how you build material.
Like you do these Poppins,
and then he'd take that material to clubs
and then you work out some dates and
clubs and then you take it to a small
theater and then a bigger theater.
And then for him,
he can go even beyond that to an arena.
But I'm saying the process is that you
remove your feelings about what he's
done. You're talking about
comedy now, stand up.
Now we're going to, you know, we're,
we're going to act like the, uh,
well, what, what are people saying
about them? Let's start there. Well,
that's the thing, it's like, first of all,
the idea that you're judging
a workout set is insane.
I get it. If you're from, from the
general public and you're going like,
what are you talking about?
But the point is you do those
sets to be kind of reckless.
You do that, you speak irresponsibly,
and then you figure out,
like there's parts that let's say,
really don't get a laugh or get an, uh,
as you move along or you go too
far. All that, that that broke,
that didn't ban, and then I'm going to
reign it in here and there of course.
And then you fit, you reign it
in and you kind of go like, okay,
well this is how I'll, you know, I'll
make these changes. But if you release,
I mean you can release the 10th time
you've worked out your set. Yeah.
So that part's crazy to me that
people in comedy are like, Oh,
it's this and it's that. It's like,
dude, it's not done and you know better.
That's sharepoint as a
craftsman is someone who's
been doing this for 20 years.
Of course. What are you talking
about? Why are you asking my draft?
It's a frustrates draft and that,
so that part made me crazy.
Then the like,
just the need to really
beat the shit out of him.
His comedy. I'm like, what
are you doing? Why are you,
why are you doing what you're saying
is so people are now saying like, oh,
he's so thoughtless. He's acting like
an old grumpy man against millennials.
And it's like, well,
he was always that Pov.
Louie hasn't changed his POV at
all. It is exactly like, yeah,
here's what makes me crazy. Somebody,
if you go, there's people who go like,
I've never found that guy funny. I've
always said he's not funny. Okay.
You don't have to like everybody
that makes sense. There's, I'd have,
but people who are like,
I was a big fan and now,
now I heard this and now I hate him.
I'm like,
what are you talking about?
Like it's the same sensibility.
It's the same guy doing the same
type of material. He's done it.
It's like vintage Louis the
same thing except now, you know,
something so weird and dark
about this person. Yeah.
And can you still know that and, and
like him. And I think what's interesting,
and if you look back at all the artists,
a lot of people that you've loved
have been colossal pieces of shit.
If you look at, well, Hey r Kelly
who's inside guys now, right?
The crazy stuff he's done.
And can you listen to his music?
Elvis Presley was banging on the syllabi.
Presley who was 15 years old,
Jerry Lee Lewis marries his 13
year old cousin. To be fair,
all those guys way bigger pieces of
Shit, right? Like not even close.
Right? But I'm saying can you
separate the man from his work?
And that's always the
big philosophical debate.
I personally like on the
comedy side of things,
listening to that and then hearing
people purposely deliberately tried to
characterize it as a alt right,
right.
Right now they're like, oh,
he's a old washed up hack.
What are you talking about?
Like even,
and here's the thing,
it kind of shows you that if you decide
to frame something as such and start
telling people and they
people go along with it,
then it becomes a truth.
It's like trailers.
It's like when they were recording
trailers with different music,
like the shining and making it a comedy.
It really is about Lens and point of view
and framing except that here's the 10
here's the thing. In this situation,
like I, not in all situations,
but in this situation I'm actually so
well informed on a subject that I can't be
swayed to believe
something that isn't true.
Like I am so well informed of how this
works and what I'm listening to them,
what I'm seeing that none of the,
you know,
um,
opinions of others can make me see
something that isn't there. Yes,
I agree with you.
There is not a hackey premise.
Like what happens is people are
going like, oh, he said like, uh, uh,
these kids today are so crazy. And it's
like, well if you frame it that way,
then that's the premise.
But if you listened to it and
you actually hear what was said,
you realize it was a much
richer concept layered. Yeah,
of course. And here's what I will say too,
is that yeah, we all know what he did.
It's not right.
Then it added that I listened to the whole
hour and I laughed and I haven't had,
cause he's hilarious. I'm
telling you, and I know,
I see Camila time aside from you
and a handful of our friends,
nobody makes me laugh. And
I was like, this is, Oh,
I'm so glad that he's back and I
really fucking like it. And you know,
you struggle with that.
You Go,
can you separate what the man did from
the stuff he does, the work he does.
And Hey, I'll tell you why he's fucking
funny enough that I think I can. Yeah,
I think I'm pro dammit. He's
talented. And I was like,
can I tell you something else?
Nobody is funnier when they got nothing
to loose and Louie has lost everything.
And I think it's made him
fucking way funnier when
you're like, well, he said it.
He goes,
what are you gonna take away my birthday?
Fuck you and I love it bothers
me. I it, they're like, you know,
he's, he's had to like,
you can't act like,
just because other people
have suffered that he hasn't,
like the idea that this year has
been just a peach for him is,
is ridiculous to me. Yeah. No, it's like
they're like, yeah, but what about the,
I mean,
you could still respect that there's
other people that have been affected and
still say like, it's not like
this year has been chill for him.
Like you've been publicly shamed.
You have two teenage kids who see
this and see you all the time.
Do you think that's fun?
But they're like,
let's still kick the shit out
of him for his workout set.
Like what is going on right now?
He's really taking it, taking it.
I don't agree with it.
I don't like it.
But I do want to point
something out aside from the,
unless you had something else that I
was just thinking too, like when did it,
when did we become such a bunch
of fucking sissies that you like,
you can't have sympathy for a group or
you can't have real life feelings for
somebody for a group and yet still make
fun of them. Like what happened to that?
You know what I'm saying? For instance,
Joan Rivers, her husband was deaf, right?
And so she would make
jokes about deaf people.
And just because you joke about it
doesn't imply that you don't have sympathy
for that group. Do you know
what I mean? Like, well,
we can joke about things that he
might still feel sympathy for.
Need something to do it all the time.
But right now I'm saying people don't
have that distinction in their minds.
They think as you make fun of it,
that you're an, you're an asshole.
You're not proline.
Everybody who gets it gets it.
In other words,
people reasonable,
they get that.
And here's the other thing
that people that don't get it,
the only thing that's making us go like,
what the fuck is wrong is that
you hear them because they have,
we all share this like these platforms.
So you see them going like,
what's wrong with you? How could you
make fun of that deaf person? You know?
And so because you ingest their
nonsense, you go, oh my God,
everything's fucking, my hands are
numb. But what I was going to say,
it's fucking kiss. My face is frozen too.
It just, uh, let me put on my jacket.
No, you know what's, what,
here's my theory on these people that
come out against the dark comedians,
these social justice warriors. To
me, I'll tell you what the theory is.
I think these guys are so afraid
of their own dark sidedness.
They're so afraid of the demons within
them that they're going to call it out in
somebody else. I you,
you're bad. You're sinful.
It's just like the preacher who's
hating the gaze and not, you know,
the homosexuals are going to burn and
it's the same guy who was blowing other
guys in the bathroom stall and doing
crystal meth. Right? Like Ted Haggard.
I gotta say you usually
don't say anything smart,
but I think you're pretty
off the chill in the air.
It's really chill in the air is
making your brain work. Okay.
I'm serious though. I tell you what,
these fuckers that are co Colin Louie out,
first of all, for those of you
don't know it, standup comic code,
it is just an unspoken code that you don't
Shit on another dude for what they're
doing creatively.
You don't Shit on other comics,
end up not understand that we can
critique on your personal life,
but it is nobody's
fucking business and free.
And for people to call the
general public become it's code.
You never fucking do it.
And the fact that these guys are doing it,
it's I think despicable and it
goes against everything creative.
And there you go. There I fucking
said it. Yeah, I just got, dammit.
I was bothered by it. I think we're
both potter. Do we have a minute?
Oh yeah.
So yes.
What I wanted to talk about it was,
it was so fucking funny the other
day when you were telling me,
Oh, I hear so much. Yeah. So what
was going on? And you're like,
I'm really having,
oh,
I was having anxiety about the baby and
he was getting sick or something and I
went to have dinner or we're
going away and you're like,
I just, you know, I just feel it.
I'm worried about the baby. I'm like,
I don't think he's really sick. He's been
coughing. I got to go to the dot. No,
we just had a cold. But I in my
mom brain, I'm like, oh fuck,
we gotta go to the doctor again tomorrow.
I hope he's okay.
I hope it's not the croup, blah,
blah, blah. And then I'm like,
and I look to you for comfort
and, and you go here, watch this.
This'll, this'll cheery up. No, I just
go, you gotta see this? Gotta see this.
I set up my phone, I give it to him. Like,
watch this, watch this. And it's the, uh,
the trailer for us, the new
Jordan Peele movie, you know,
is that a Romcom instead of a
jaunt? It's good for anxiety. Sure.
Because especially about
your children. Yeah. Perfect.
It's um, but the, the trailers
amazing. And uh, I was,
I was pretty stoked. He
takes a, I got five on it,
the loonies track from
the 90s and slows it down.
And so it sets this tone for
this deeply disturbing thriller.
And then you were like, what the fuck
are you making me watch this for? I said,
I'm anxious.
I think the one thing you don't give
somebody when they're anxious is a horror
movie trailer.
No.
It really made me laugh about like
losing your kids and stuff too. I'm like,
it was pretty great. It was pretty
great. It would be like here,
watch the new Jodi foster movie on.
I can't do this shit man.
Thank you for doing that. Tom, you always
know how to really make me feel good.
You are welcome.
Well look at
gene,
so excite.
We should take a moment and
we'll be back with great guest
right after these words.
Your mom's house.
We'll be right back. All right,
and we are back. All right,
pretty good and we're back with
an all timer, a hall of Famer.
First ballot.
I'm you so excited.
We're so excited
that you're here.
11 your voice goes love when your voice
that you're octaves and pitch change,
but we're also not just excited
that you're here to show you stuff,
but we're also so excited to announce
that you are going to be doing an
additional you only you know you don't
work hard enough or we have thrown your
way.
Yes,
you're going to be doing a podcast out
of here on our second set that we have
here. Let's be fair. We should we be
calling it a podcast. It's a youtube,
it's a full on extreme. They,
all this stuff you have here,
it's going to be deployed for that.
Let's call it a pod for the moment. Sure.
A show. It's a show. It's a
show. It's a show. Um, that we,
here's the cool thing.
We,
we respected that when you first came on
it was just like, hey, would you come on?
And it was, I was fans of both
you guys. That's very nice. And I,
and I kind of knew what your mom's house
when I did not know what I was going to
be subjected to,
nor did I know what a sadist your wife is.
So enjoy my discomfort or that
the audience would really enjoy.
Well, it's your audience.
So I think the discomfort,
I think we enjoy having a professional
opinion on what's going on. To be fair,
not just the clips,
but I was uh,
I was reflecting today when I was thinking
about coming over here and how joyous
I was and they were, and sort of,
I wanted to congratulate you guys.
I'm excited for you.
You have the opening volley with these
guys was does far to push stool out or
not. This is why we have you on the
show. And I thought, wow, so here we are.
Here we are. We're coming full
circle that your medical degree, Oh,
I've been to radio long time and
sort of nothing surprises me.
However that moment stayed with me,
puts the shit out of shits,
push the farm
and then we played for you a
tons of funny clips. Funny.
Yeah. So, um, funny.
That was funny, right?
The guy that was a snake bite biting it.
I didn't get to see none of that was
just audio. Okay. Yeah. He's just,
he's just funny. People's misery is funny,
right? That what I'm supposed to eat
seriously reflecting on all this
this morning. The other thing.
The other thing is,
aside from your ugly at my discomfort,
the other thing was Tom's genuine joy
at people's misery. He was like, yes,
yes, this is joyous. And it was that,
that likes a layer of discomfort on
me that I almost couldn't tolerate it.
So that's where the discomfort really
goes over the top and I came back,
I've made maintain friendships and,
and not only that,
I'm going to be a part of this,
this shift pirate ship. Well,
here's the thing I wanted to like
in summary is that you came on,
you didn't know what to
expect, uh, the audience.
So loved having your voice in this world.
And then that's what
led to the idea of like,
what if you did a show here where it,
it's a little mix up of like,
you know, speaking of things that you
want to talk about your in your own lane,
commenting on clips from the show,
which seems to be like a
really fun thing to happen.
And then talking to some people to hold
that comedian. Yes. Deconstructing them.
Oh my God. After dark dude, I love it.
That's what it's going to be. All the
fun that you're talking about. Sex,
drugs and rock and roll
and crazy comedians.
And I want you to psycho analyze all
the comments. I'll do the best I can.
So fascinated by that.
Is it your own stuff and your husband now?
Yes.
I'm fascinated by human beings and I
just thought about how we is my voice in
this world is that,
what'd you say to them in this world and
this world and this world. And it is a,
it is an alternative universe over here
and you should know that your fans are
quite enthusiastic.
Yes.
I was at a MTV movie awards.
Did I tell you this story?
And a woman flew out of the booth to like,
I had just gone over and gushed
at, uh, what's the kids name?
That shit's creek. Uh, it's, I don't
know. Shit's creek is a great show here.
Oh really? I don't like many comedy.
Uh, Dan, I forget his last days.
He's there anyway.
And the Levy Dan Levy,
it was gushing over at him is, he's the
other ones. What's The dad's name? Eugene.
Eugene's Day.
The Dad and uh,
and I was just gushing at him and then
I was literally nearly tackled by one of
your fans who was like a
35 year old female. I mean,
not exactly what I expected,
right? Of attractive 35 year
old female who like, who,
who seemed sane but was behaving insane.
And I say this with peace and love,
peace and love, peace and love.
She was one of the lovely
woman would not leave.
I couldn't get enough like wanting
to be a part of this world.
We encourage that you,
you did it him,
if anybody sees drew body
camera guy wasn't bothersome.
It was not bothered. She was,
she was much like Christina.
I was an observer of this human
behavior and thinking, wow,
this is a different world,
but I become a part of and I better
double down on our show on it.
Our fans,
let's put it this way,
they have transformed Garth Brooks
is social media, right? Tommy,
what did you say? That we've taken
over? We've take things by storms.
So just be prepared but
not be, there's, look,
there's limited time with you and there's
a lot of money. Here's what I want to,
first of all, I want, I want
to be your videos. Yeah. Yeah.
So here's what I wanted to,
uh,
so this has been the latest like thing
that blew up on the show and to set it
up. I'd love to get your
whole thought on this. Okay.
So here's what happened.
I feel like here's the setup.
Let me just tell you.
Okay.
I feel like somebody who like either
like needed major dental work,
like revisions in their mouth going in.
Now again, I'm like, okay, here we go.
I'm used to this, but don't start
drilling. I love it. Okay, so,
so are like a cancer patient,
get testicular cancer has
getting chemo and going,
Oh God, you're right.
All right. Here we go.
So I just went like,
okay,
I want to give you the setup because
it makes more sense this way.
Here's the setup
man. Was that the gym? Is
that this guy? Yes. Okay.
He was at the gym and he sees
an attractive woman. Okay.
Leaving the tanning room at the gym sees
that she had signed in at the sign in
sheet. Was this pre or post
to be too? This is pre. Oh,
so there should be a few years. But
he's, he signed, he sees her sign in,
so he knows her name. Okay. Okay.
So when what he does with his,
he's think he's on the spot.
He goes, you know what,
I'm going to follow her out into the
parking lot. And he says her name.
Do you want to be listeners and viewers?
No, he's behaving like one. Right.
This is pretty nice. It's pretty,
oh,
advance keeps going.
That's where your listeners cut off and
the right videos began. That's right.
So this guy
sees her, he calls out her
name. Her name's Julia.
And she thinks that
because he knows her name,
that we must be let me
show. She's like, yes.
And he's just tells her like, Oh, you
know, I saw you here, blah, blah, blah.
I'd like to take you out.
Sometimes. She's like, well,
I'm kind of thinking about getting
back with my ex, you know, he's like,
how about just dinner? Uh, can I
have your number? And she goes,
how about I'll take your number and one
of those movies. And she shows her phone,
cause it's in her hand.
He puts in his number and dials himself,
has her know. So, but that's where
she goes, thanks. Good night.
And then she goes home and the next
morning she wakes up and this has been
texted to her number, this video. And is
she, she the one that sent this to you?
Well, eventually it yet,
but yes, we're listeners.
And then we ended up meeting
her and getting the story.
But so I just wanted to get
your take on this as a hello
as a,
I met you yesterday or their
body fluids involved. Julia.
Just me.
Joe just wanted
to say hi.
Wish you a great day.
Tell you that meeting you yesterday and
getting a look at you was probably one
of the greatest moments of my life.
You were so beautiful.
You don't know how beautiful you are
to me. I mean just, you're gorgeous.
You're precious.
There's more perfectly
normal. Perfectly okay.
Does he pull the gun up to his head?
You're going to,
you're going to go out with me or else,
but it's been sitting in my
mind when you said to me,
you want to go back with
your ex boyfriend, please
erase him from your memory.
Don't ever go back in the past.
I know,
cause I've been there and I understand
when you know you're trying to find
somebody and you go on dates and nothing
compares to Eurex but there is that
better person out there and Giulia,
I promise you it is me.
Perfectly normal.
Perfectly natural.
Does he hasn't threatened to kill
the boyfriend? Yeah, that's okay.
It's just pillow like you've never
been loved before. I will cherish you.
I'll make you feel like a woman,
a real woman. I believe me.
After you experience mate, you won't
even know who your ex boyfriend is.
Here we go. We're going down. We're going
down.
He these is this all one video. One
video, but it's chopped up. Okay.
Put up your heart to make in your ARVs.
Let's go full throttle.
I could see me falling in love with you.
It just so I don't know. I just
looked in your eyes and I just melt.
Oh yeah. So he's still open
the pathetic zone. Okay. Okay.
I feel bad. What are you waiting for?
You're waiting for it to cross into. Well,
hold on. So I'm expecting,
I'm heading off.
I'm expecting either some sort of
totally sexually inappropriate move,
which then will get disgusting or
some sort of threat of violence.
It's expecting one or the other.
So
both are possible. Right? So if I were
this woman, I'd be like, Oh, Jesus Christ.
Paul cops are called the MCI.
Okay.
Okay. Anyhow, I've had an off to work.
This is my cute little home.
Everything you see behind me,
I built everything every square inch
from crown mold into chair rail,
the floors to lighting, to
plumbing, doors, windows
speaking,
have lighting.
Does he have like some special like
Instagram lighting in his kitchen?
Did you see that? Yeah, they looked
like pretty well, like weird.
The weird lighting. Okay. Pretty unique.
Yes. Do you want him to work on your own?
No.
Does the type of guy, again,
I'm a very handy guy and uh,
I'd love to build you. Whatever
you want. Oh, you're a sweetheart.
So I hope this video doesn't scare
you. Oh, sorry. How I feel sorry,
dude, I just want you to that. Okay. Okay.
Now I look forward.
I'm going out to dinner with you,
so let's make it happen.
Nah,
dude, I'm so sorry. What do you think's
going on with this guy? What's going on?
What do you think's going on
this layered?
What's, what's wrong with you man?
Peace and love. Peace and love.
I don't know this guy. I don't
know you sir. I don't know you sir.
I don't mean to disparage you,
but laughing.
You guys don't understand something.
You now have your physician on your
platform. Liability comes with that
piece and a law of peace and love.
This is strictly in analysis based
on a video and not knowing this man,
but I mean, it's a kind of a narcissism,
right? I mean, it's a, it's a,
it's not really processing reality
in that reading social cues.
You worry that it flips into sociopathy
where she's just an object for him.
And so, you know, it doesn't
really, yeah. Mattered to him.
What she's thinking or feeling because
he's decided she's the one now his
defense. How would you say this guy is?
This guy was probably 45 really? Yeah,
I was hoping. So 27 well, I,
you should know there's lots of this
going on in the twenties really? Yeah.
Lots of stock.
This is stalking behavior essentially.
Socking as always.
There's no
needles.
They because they were you
happy with this is fascinating.
So, so he, I have to
breathe deep in this place.
I love this house.
Um,
they are not doing normal sort of dating.
They don't,
they don't form and break relationships
normally during adolescence. Right.
We'd normally,
you have them and break them and have
them and break them and you date none of
that. It's all sort of
hooking up and hanging out.
And so when they actually developed sort
of a real attraction or an attachment
to somebody,
they don't know what to do with it.
They don't know how to navigate that. A
manager. So we get a lot of people going,
males 27 or more like 25 going,
uh, well I met the girl might,
I met her at the girl of my dreams and
we went out and she wouldn't so into it,
but uh, that was just there and you
know, she was, she didn't understand it.
So we became friends and we're good
friends and I've been waxing her car and
cleaning. Yeah. Carpet the last
two years. And now it's time.
And those two years I've
been stalking. Right. Wow.
He's hanging out stalking weight and now
he's like, now you need to it's time.
Well, can I tell you the full story
now? Oh No. So he followed her.
Oh, she found out where her ex
lived. So it was real stock.
And then he disemboweled that man
on the freeway in New Jersey. No,
just
in your head please let it go.
Let it,
let us see where I go with [inaudible]
to lie to somebody and let you believe
that. Horrible. It's like,
that's my dad. No, I don't have
the heart to torture you. I like,
my husband didn't know that.
That didn't happen the last,
but he did send a few more
videos. He, yeah, she was,
she able to get rid of him.
Now he is aware of his creepiness
because at one point he goes,
I hope this doesn't scare you.
Like there's an awareness there is and it,
but it's a dismissing of it. Right, right.
It's like it's like you, you wouldn't,
of course you wouldn't be, you know,
you're not scared by me. Of course I,
because it's me and I hope it doesn't
do it because it won't anyway.
Cause it's me. It's, yeah. And the
duration of this stuff and the,
so let me ask you then for a word to me,
I get very sad when I see a car.
He said usual when I watched your what?
See,
this is why we're interesting.
So when I see people get run into in
a garage and their legs get cut off,
I feel bad when I see this
guy. Right. You're, you're,
your production staff has probably
never seen us in action cause they're
laughing their asses off. He
goes like this. I feel bad
for them because, you know,
it's interesting,
I was listening to podcasts.
Are you saying they're all like the
persuasion has become a really hot topic
lately I think because of Trump and
that's all he's doing is using persuasion
and uh, and people go, you must got
to take other people's point of view.
Let's see the point of view when I go,
no,
that's all I do all day is I try to
put myself in there literally in their
shoes,
in their body and feel it not,
not invade their body
or be overtaken by it,
but to really try to
understand what that is. Sure.
And so I automatically see this guy and I
just, Oh, poor dude. Oh man, it's so bad.
So bad. So sad. Desperate.
Right. I ruined it.
I ruined the whole thing.
Now is even funnier.
We've actually gone back.
Good Morning Julia, which is how this
starts. God, let me ask you this.
True for the women listening because I
in my twenties had guys like this too who
didn't seem to understand boundaries
and that I wasn't interested.
How should a woman deal with
something like the guy to fuck them?
You got a fucking guy.
I was going to say that I let them know
[inaudible] go get out of here.
So that when you were going to say,
sorry.
No I was going to say from
just very firm but non amo,
not hysterical or emotional I think
and, and, and then that'll ramp it up.
Well any contact ramps it up, right.
So you have to be firmed, deliberate,
swift and sure. And then no
more contact cause any contact.
How about a deliberate text back? Like
let's say girl gets this kind of video,
what is the text back to the texting
or emails that kind of is a good idea
because you have a documentation and just
say any and really make it any further
contact.
Here is what I'm gonna do.
I'm gonna contact the FBI and the
local police. You are freaking me out.
I'm sorry.
It'd be kind but firm at free and clear
in no cracks in the wall cause they will
exploit any crack and any future
and they will escalate it.
So no blowjobs nothing.
Don't, sorry Tommy. I know,
I know it worked for
you a couple of times.
That's why they keep doing it cause
it keep working. Right. So um,
oh okay.
Yeah.
So we've been really fascinated by Garth
Brooks. And I want to tell you, oh,
I here. Okay. I'm not sure I understand
why. And by the way, it's not that we're,
we're not shitting on his music
or his talent. It's nothing. Yeah.
He was super talented guy who's
unbelief has an unbelievable fan base,
right? Yeah. But he has
a dark side. I think so.
And I also think that he has
this really disconnected,
um, sense of like how to
interact with, right. So, so the,
so Garth book, the human being is
probably different than the guy.
See what the hat up there on the day
probably carefully protected that they
manage. Right? Right. That's for your evil
because of this like country music
fan base where it's like, oh shucks,
I just like it bacon
pie with my daughters.
I think something, boom, here's the thing,
the cracks in his real self show in these,
so obviously his team was like,
you need to be on social media
and he's probably reluctant.
I don't know if you've ever seen the
initial, do you have when he, I've not,
I've not gone down the Garth
Brooks prep. Okay. With you.
You have the initial announcement
that he's joining Facebook or no,
is that Qta I don't have that. You
don't have that? Okay. Well then this,
I want to see this. This is not well
here. Well, this is a, okay, so this is,
he has inside studio g, which is, uh,
like his behind the scenes look for the
fans where it's a studio and it's access
to, you know, here's where it works.
Stuff out, always with a smile.
Everything's always glorious. Every, I'm
always in a good mood, everything's great.
And his wife is Tricia.
Tricia,
or can you do this
thing? Oh, oh, oh Jesus.
Oh dear. Your cod. As she's doing
that, she's very hard question.
I don't know why women,
but as he doing this segment for his,
like behind the scenes show, I think it's
like his Facebook channel or something.
Uh, a door opens. Oh,
he's just so we get to it.
Like what was the Welsh guy's name that
was on the Golden Globe with a heavy
accent? Yeah, Christian Bale. Notice
my name finding as I get older.
Sorted your best Christian Bale,
like a Christian Bale moment where we
screams at the staff. Remember that?
You'll see, you'll see
certain, yeah. Let me just say,
unfortunately what I'm
seeing, just looking at the
picture here, peace and love,
peace and love. I don't
know. Garth Brooks,
a little bit of what we call Plethora Ra.
I'm gonna pull through a
little bit of little Billy,
a little bit of parotid and large,
maybe some booze maybe. Let's see. Okay,
so here's this clip. Let's take a look at.
Nothing wrong with that. Yeah, no, I know.
I just don't want to say, yeah. Let's
see. Let's take a look at this clip,
but you just looking at this
point, it's a small, small moment.
I just want to get your thought.
All right. Very subtle. So I got,
is that supposed to happen?
[inaudible]
happy birthday.
Do you think he murdered whoever knocked
on the door or no, he would have a,
we're not a birthday. We'll
be that. We'll look at that.
That's what I'm talking about. Dart.
Dart. That's supposed to happen.
The rage,
the quiet at a very,
very good seething rage that's supposed
to happen and that wasn't good this time.
Last time was more, we'll do it again.
Does that supposed to have, there we go.
Yeah. Yeah. But you sense it too,
right? Like he's seeding blink, SOS,
Christina [inaudible] problem at all.
He's just blank. I'll be her pretty tired.
We every week on Friday.
Okay. Um, no. Yeah,
that's uh,
okay.
So he's got an aggressive side to him
that we didn't know that for sure.
Just check, check guy.
But to be fair to him,
I mean, he's like, he's like a crazy
superstar. You know what I mean?
Who knows what he's used
to and can't tolerate it.
Maybe he's tired and so I'm willing
to just go. Maybe that was a moment.
Maybe I really like that.
Does he smoke cigarettes now?
But sometimes he'll talk real
sexy and some of his voice,
so he does other gutter of the fried.
It's going to ask you tube.
Have you heard of his alter ego?
Chris Gaines. Oh my God, what is this?
You don't know that.
That's the Goth version.
So he did this thing for a while where
he put on a different persona called
Chris Gaines where he was kind of golf
looking and he even Photoshop his face to
be thinner and gaunt and more
and more sensitive and it was,
it wasn't,
I don't think its fan base appreciates
it as much as they appreciate what gets
it back story for it so
that like Chris Gaines,
his parents died when he was young. Oh my
God. So He's, he's trying to capitalize,
he wants to be like a grunge artists.
He went for it and he put out an album
as this and then he nearly wiped the
Internet clean of it after he
decided not to do it anymore.
It's pretty interesting.
You guys have tapped into something.
I'm not a conspiracy theorist,
but I think you found something for here.
Does he have a civilization
on the backside of the
moon that Chinese are going
to dig in mind? Let's,
let's talk. He's Tom
for his latest towards stadium, but he's
a huge superstar. Yeah, that's a big deal.
It's pretty wild. Right?
And you don't know.
We really don't know what
that does to people. Right.
But that's the thing is I think a big,
like a big part of what we're picking
up on with him and being kind of just
weird is that I can't imagine what
that level of fame does to you.
It just will.
Especially there,
there's sort of a confluence of factors
is the kind of person that seeks that
kind of fame.
The kind of person that we as a society
elevate to that kind of paint, paint,
fame and then what it does to them.
This was a confluence of factors.
It's now it's not the fame itself,
right? It's that seething rage.
It was already there. I'm just saying.
And the intolerance is probably, you know,
just the overworking and the alcohol and
whatever else. Where else, I dunno. Pills,
whatever. You know, I
feel like I've got, um,
the insult dog behind you.
What,
what is this is for pup play.
It's not sexual.
That's not sexual at all.
You seen those people that they wear
masks and then they pretend to be dogs and
smell each other's butts. But it's
not, it's not sexual. It's just a, hey,
I see that. Please Tom, may I
please you want to see this?
I want to see that because we have seen
furries and I imagine this is sort of a
furry part, but when you got to the
sniffing of this, but Christina,
maybe that's your version of the dog.
Do you have a dog mass clip?
Uh, well on my show you'll have
to tune into my show. I will,
I will. I will, uh,
look into this and maybe we should
have a dog, but play every week,
maybe something like that.
They have a theme or professional
counsel on this as well.
The other day I was experiencing some
anxiety on the drive home from dinner with
my husband. You know the baby was sick
was when we all went out to dinner.
Oh my God,
we're stuck with this guy.
And I was like, Gosh, you know I'm
experiencing anxiety and he goes, here,
watch this. It's really good. It's
really good. This is this, by the way,
does Susan know you're putting out
like you're doing webcam stuff alone?
Is this you? This is me. Is that
not you? It could be. Let's see.
You wouldn't be required
to make daddy call.
What she recorded me. I didn't
know. I didn't put it up. She did it
be done in a way,
but you want to do either with your body
or a friend of yours that's a girl that
you can sell with picture and
saved that he stroke to her.
Yeah, normal. Perfectly natural.
Does it. Perfectly healthy.
But he reminds me of like
a Spiderman evil villain.
He's like w w like I
wonder what he's like.
I would love to see him in his real life.
You know what I mean?
That's the part that I find
fascinating. Like, this is such a, this,
I guarantee you this piece of him is
something that he puts way out over here.
He had denies it exists. Oh, right.
Then he goes through his life as a bank
president. Right. You know what I mean?
And then what is that doing that
compartmentalize and partly it's trauma.
It's true that this traumatized piece
of himself that comes out in once while
needs, needs attention, but he's like,
it's detached though. It's disconnected.
Trauma is morphed into a sexual
as it is. Oh, is that right?
It's one form or not. I mean, let's
put it this way. I'm sorry guys.
It always has a,
let's put it this way.
I'm not saying there's a
direct correlation between
trauma and sexual fetishes.
I'm saying that when you're traumatized
and naturally it affects important parts
of your life, like your sexuality. Right?
And so especially when you have a cutoff
part of yourself that may be injured
and dysfunctional,
I don't know what's there.
That need is aggressive and angry and
whatever, so it'll act itself out. Wow.
Hey, good time man. It didn't seem like
the healthiest message to put out. Right.
Did this, uh, alleviate
your anxiety? You saw this
trailer for a horror film? It's a
Jordan peals new movie. US that,
that trailer just what
do you think of that?
Does that like Asperger's where he
doesn't read the social cues or cues,
how to document these things?
Because one day there will be a court case
and child custody will come with the
question, so you're going to need this.
Just keep that licensed physician list.
What?
You know what's interesting?
The last I was trying to show her
that trailer all day, so I was like,
you have you seen the trailer?
And then that dinner, I was like,
have you seen the trailer? And then
we were in the car and I was like,
you got to see it. And then when I
showed, she was like, I'm anxious. Oh
He's speaking of which can I hit burden
my show immediately I sort of created
bird. Do you know this?
You don't know this.
What do you mean the first
time you told them that him?
Of course he didn't do that.
But the first time he told them
the machine story was on love line.
I made him come back the next
night and tell it again. Really?
He said I should go out and tell
this story in public. And he's,
that was his career began when you ask
it. If that's not the case. That's true.
And I love him in the certain kind of
way and I wonder his podcast to it.
We should, I should go over and do his
and promote all this stuff. Fantastic.
I mean, we should all go over
there and do it or something.
That'd be great last night
and drank a lot. He drinks.
It was neat because most
pieces of Tobar I have a,
I have scotch or bourbon and
a, you know, put it in a nice,
they're like nice glasses for
it. Yeah. And uh, you know,
usually it's like halfway
kind of pores have it serve.
He would then he would do it poor and do
it to the rim of the glass. Oh my God.
Of the necks of the
niceness and glad is rough.
That is rough. I don't know.
There's a man that puts the car,
the call out for somebody
to be his baby daddy thing.
Yeah. And then what's the woman
like who, who's answering the call?
It is also somebody injured who wants to
explore to make money from injured men.
It's a prostitutes is
going to be somebody.
It's somebody who was
also compartmentalize,
but as I will tolerate it to
a certain point and fuck it.
I'll just be interesting.
And what about women who make fart videos?
What's the deal? I could
do that. And what's the,
you'd be the cake Fart, I think, right?
She was sitting in the cakes farting.
I know her, right Tom? I got, yeah,
I got it. Is it really that wrong?
She always sees, you know,
sometimes we played uh, like uh,
dom videos and like there's this
one where they like, they'll,
there's some guys who actually
like getting kicked in
the balls and punching the
them really hard to why? Yeah.
Have you seen killing eve yet?
What's that? Oh, you'll go
insane for this killing eve. Wow.
It's like a nine part series,
but it's what Sandra, Oh,
won the golden globe for them. Oh
really? Yeah. And it's uh, it is she eve,
she's w they're actually
in a weird way to Eve's,
but she's one of the eaves and the,
um,
and I can't explain
about you're seeing it,
but there's a scene where a guy gets
his balls clamped and like I said,
I don't know. I mean we've, we've
watched these for a laugh and it's,
it's really crazy to,
and sometimes I got to tell you there's,
there's a lot of stuff that I just
don't fully get what I mean, I'm like,
like I don't know that you physically
can, can get by or get Polish with. Yeah,
me too. I don't quite get it. Every time
we've watched these things, she goes,
I could do that. I could do, I
could, that'd be fun to do it.
She expresses show me one, I want to see
your reaction. We'll see it in real time.
Can you show me once we don't have a week,
clearly I have to come back.
You have to come back. Yeah.
That's another thing for him. Yeah,
we actually were having to, my truck
is, we're actually running out of time,
but there's like, all
right, I will be back.
I'll be back and come watch my
show here on this platform. So
we didn't even mention there's
a fart Mike here. Mike,
if you have a fire. Love it. Did
she say my con? Yes, many times. Um,
by the way, uh, we had a new hats
made or no, if you like these.
Oh, I'm not sure Rachel,
and I'll let you have that.
How did we get those emails
working on the, the lights? I think
it was Mel. Yeah, the lighting designer
worked on a show and he brought these in.
So anyways, would you like one or no,
it's okay. I want to give him to the fans.
Okay. Yeah, we're selling
them for like, do I wear the
thing all the time. Oh really?
Oh cool. You know, the last
stand, if I saw you did,
you spoke differently about your dad that
I've ever heard you talk about? Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Usually I didn't know.
It was funny cause I have Christina's
idealised view of your dad, right? Yeah.
And you were a little bit more realistic,
let's say.
Probably closer to I,
I'm interested in that too.
As time goes on we'll,
we'll dig into that a little bit.
Dad loved it, but whenever you say,
hear me use the word Wunderman,
it's, it's that I wonder, I wonder.
I'm thinking our money, whatever.
Whenever I see right. That's how I know.
Cause I've heard you say right, but
even you know it, even when you know it,
it still works. It still
works. It works no matter what.
I know it's one of those things.
She goes,
I have a fantasy that bump up by and I'm
like, God dammit. Is that what I'm doing?
And then she's great. She gets it every
time. So how have you been therapy?
10 years? I did 11 years and I contemplate
going back for a psychoanalysis.
We love to do that. I'll
tell you it. Yeah. Anyway,
I've got a great lady I'd like
to add or a psycho analysis,
but I had to commit to like four or five
times a week at staff would want to sit
on one of your sessions to see,
literally,
literally I wrote my therapist
and node years later I went,
how the fuck did you tolerate that
boring bullshit for all those years?
That's really no. Nothing like you
can be. No, I think they get bored.
I'm sure you get bored.
I mean, no, cause she,
she was very attuned and
she's busy attuning to be,
and that's what I needed
and I'm still like,
how did you tolerate all the droll
and nonsense for all those years?
Just like thank you for just sitting
through that because there really wasn't
anything to complain about.
I have a good life.
My parents were shitty. Yes. Oh,
that's plenty to complain about.
So I did it for 10 years. Yes, I meant,
but that's how long it takes
to get into that. I know.
And I had sort of trauma light compared
to what some people experience,
you know what I mean? So, yeah. But don't.
Don't minimize your trauma. Thank you Tom.
Thank you Allen.
But we celebrate trauma on this show.
Oh yes you do. Yes you do. Is there
more video from me? Is there one more?
I don't know it come.
Daddy is, was that it?
Well we want it to be
cognisant of your time.
I'm kind of running out and stuff but
I'll come back to do we have two on the w
on the books now? We
got to do already. Yeah.
There's a couple of things we definitely
have to show him when he comes back.
We've got to get deep into the dog
thing cause I think, well the smell,
it has a smell.
It's important.
Talks about smell and creating your own
smell too. Like smell like Jesus, stop.
I'll get to see this.
But top was so gross.
When you finger on the crack,
gas does smell it.
Okay, so on these matters, that's
different. That's a guy. What's he saying?
That's only smells. Okay. He's,
he's having anal sex with a woman pulls
out and there's some shit on his day and
then she's like, I don't want to do
it anymore. He goes, it's only submit.
It's just okay to get her
to keep doing it. It just,
it just speaks volumes about men. That
is his kneecaps could be bleeding out,
falling out. He'd be like,
it's just, just keep going.
You go and they do keep going.
That's the amazing thing. He really,
to me the more amazing part is not him
but the woman that he's going like,
what the hell?
We also have clips of delusional men
who are like missing teeth and clearly
disheveled in, they're
like, I want a virgin.
I want a woman who 120 pounds only
the best for me and what is wrong?
Can you play for him real
quick to see is like a minute,
just today's opening clip.
Just the first just to get him
like [inaudible] properly. Well,
just to see like what would you
think is going on with this guy?
I mean like whenever
you open with that Tom,
I get a shutter down my spine.
What's going on with this guy?
I just want to see what's
going on. Yeah, go ahead.
All Yo beautiful women. You
feel me? This let me eat you.
One term is,
let me eat your one time and you go,
I guarantee you you're gonna, you're
gonna ask me to stick to your house.
You go here, you go to sleep
for three days. My baby
and he goes on. I love him.
He's pretty great, right?
I haven't lovely offers to cook and clean.
Oh my God,
this is just take a bath when
you get home. If I were a woman,
he'd be Damn fucking bring him. He's
my husband. Yeah. How could you not be?
It's just overtaken by that and somehow
somewhere really put together on buddy
actually went for that. That's why he's
able to do that. I would like to know who,
probably a mirror image.
I'm expecting
we can find her in your video pile too.
But now I'm wondering,
I'm really wondering what's going on.
Is He, is he on the streets? Do we know?
It looks like a, it's kind of like that,
right? Yeah, it's a yard
somewhere. It's astonishing to me.
There's this,
this world of
skis oid skis to effective schizophrenia,
that sort of zone,
the things they can believe about
themselves and their place in the world is
always just, just delusion,
delusional and it to me,
and it may be subtly delusional, like you
can call this settle if you want. Yeah.
I call it kind of subtle. Uh, and it's,
to me that's just, I just, I just,
it's one of the, I have zones,
right? Like I can't like process.
This is one of those zones.
You can't wait.
I can't relate because I have low self
esteem and I don't feel I feel small and
that important and stuff.
And to have somebody go, hey
man, let's go. I'm the batch,
I should be the president.
And the truth is you could
probably eat somebody real well,
but you're just putting out
videos like that and maybe hit it.
He'd have to like build up to that point
where he could actually gauge and said,
behavior. Call me crazy,
Colby. Fucking crazy.
A good, bad for my soul. This is going
to be bad for my soul. I know it.
That's why I'm having this horrible
thought. Like, Oh, what have I done? Why?
But this is why I know I've got a
problem. Why do they not have teeth?
It's always part of it, isn't
it? Just on these videos,
there's poor lighting and it's what topic
did the teeth are missing? It's in a,
usually you go, oh, that must be
math or coat or something else,
but it's not necessarily a drug
addiction and it's in that schizophrenia,
schizophrenia forms cause while effective
and some of these people can be in
kind of kind of in the world, they just
aren't really in the workplace. Right.
You know what I mean? They, they,
they may be dependent on somebody and
they may kind of look sometimes seminoma
and these days they get
caps and things and see you.
If they have like a family that's taken
care of you and you miss the teeth part,
but the teeth is a, is a clue. Yes. I
think so too. Yeah. How fascinating.
Because part of not being in the
reality. Right. Right. That I,
this is all a mess and, oh,
well anyway, let's go eat
this trip.
Right.
We will. A doctor drew, I hope
your fans are happy there.
This is a, oh, that's fine.
That's amazing. And you're going to
be here. I'm going, I'm going down.
I'm going with them. I'm
going, if I need to stop now,
please go to Dr Com and give
me your thoughts. Absolutely.
Yeah. But as now I'm, I'm going
with them. And where else,
by the way, this, this pod,
you can get a Dr. Carr everything. It'd
be Dr Com. Yeah. Everything. So Graham,
what is it?
A doctor drew Pinsky and I'll do some
Instagram lives and stuff and maybe we'll
do Instagram live like maybe
routinely starting these shows. Sure,
yeah, yeah, yeah. Um, I just
wanted to say that the, uh,
the new show he'll be doing will be
available as on this youtube channel on
Fridays. Um, and it also be available
to download if you want to listen to it.
And it'll be doctor drew after
dark after dark. All right. G,
D d a
dean,
a Di Da Di da Di da Dad.
It's going to be the dad
bod. Okay. We'll be back
talking about floats and Dick's break.
So real quick,
I know,
thank you for sticking around an extra
minute or we were about to just jump off.
Yep. But, uh, but we couldn't
resist one of our producers and,
and a great comic and friend Josh Potter.
Uh,
we were talking about this
the other day. Um, Josh,
go ahead and tell what happened.
Well, uh, so Dr drew,
I just want to preface this by saying
my first job in radio was born hopping
love line really when I was
19, uh, back years ago. Where,
what studio? We've had many, many. I
worked for one oh 3.3 the edge in Buffalo,
New York. Oh, okay. So you were, okay. So
you were at one of our affiliates. Yes.
I was just bored hopping. Not Yours. It
was a satellite. Yes. Have nothing to do.
So I listened to the show often and uh,
I decided I needed help with
something, so I'd call in. Oh.
And I called in and told my problem.
And then you said, oh boy,
another delayed ejaculation call.
And then you hung up on me.
What happened? What is the one,
no, as a person who does radio,
I understand why you did what you did.
The show needed to move and you need it.
I wasn't in control of the phones as
well, so it wasn't me. I'm sure. No,
I think it producer maybe hung up on it
and it's a Corolla. But go ahead. Okay.
Yes, no. So I, I never got the
ants. All right here we can also,
it's still well, yes, yes, yes, of
course. Well, no. So I mean it is
still an issue and I have not, I have not
read it. It is the fact that I can stay,
I can maintain, I just go back, go over
the top. What's that all about? So I,
I'm thinking of it more of a biological
thing that people want to make it a
psychological thing that you're not
willing to be open and free and new.
Give of yourself to the
person. Kindergarten teacher
beat him mercilessly. Okay.
Well there's that. Strangely,
that's what happened to me.
My kindergarten teacher grabbed
me and shook me to my babies.
Had I could have that done to him
and mine kindergarten. They do.
We're in the same kindergarten. I'm
sorry, back to check on his dick. So,
uh, are you ever able to
I have like twice. Okay.
So what of course went with myself
of course. Right. So we did,
unfortunately it has to do is
bring himself right to the point,
has he knows how to do and then
include his partner in his head.
Then I really think it's, it's,
it's, it's very hard to treat.
And I think one of the reasons is
where her treated cause he didn't so
biological, it's just, I, I understand it.
The guys that tend to be more on the
premature side, it seems incomprehensible,
but that's cause that biologist so
very different. And uh, there is no,
I mean people talk about
treatments and things.
I've never seen anything that's really
very effective other than you got to work,
you have to have a steady partner,
you have to work with him
or her regularly on this.
And they have to be sort of willing
to kind of go along with it.
The big thing would be like a
regular partner would probably,
I just need someone who can push the
right buttons. No, it's actually not that.
It's somebody who's willing to
watched you or listen to you or or,
or have you do what you need to do and
then get themselves involved in that in
various ways. We've got to
start with a coffee date first.
I think the video we learned earlier
in the show. Send a video. Yeah,
maybe with a full on how to
and that they are into that.
Do you have like really kinky little
secret things that you do to get yourself
off me? Yeah. No, not at
all. I'm pretty mundane.
I think I'm very mundane and whatever
it is you got to bring that to.
Then basically all sex though just ends
without you finishing all of it all.
All right. It can be very
effective. Right, but all like here,
every time Tom asks a question about it,
so I keep thinking I'm fast, I'm fast.
How's this work on fat
Super Fan? I understand.
I saw that every question
you asked children. Yeah.
Yeah. I mean, without kids.
I'm still just like that,
but that's my usual.
I'm just, I'm just amazed though. I'm just
amazed. I'm saying like, I want if the,
if we can get anything out of this show,
it's just for Josh to come.
So the is it, is it possible you'll
have to keep tuning in? Really?
This'll be going so well. You
help them out. Lead? Nope. No,
I don't think with your head. But
we talked to him. I'll talk to him.
Can we just it, but will you talk through
it more? She of course. Okay. I want Josh.
Josh line would be that guy.
Drudgery.
I can't wait someday. That'll
be you. One day. My Baby.
Can't wait. All right, thanks.
Thanks guys. Alright, and we're back. Uh,
we have switched out guests. We
tossed one into the trash. Oh my God.
We picked up another one.
This guest is a longtime friend
who I would venture to say is even
a Sunday.
What am I? Good buddies. Good
buddies, a great comedian,
great podcast or Ryan
Aka sickle cell second.
Look,
it's,
I'm very excited to be here at day
one of your mom's house studio?
Yes. It's studio jeans. Oh, his
studio gene inside studio jeans. Oh,
I'm inside studio jeans at your mom's
house. I just got to learn the lingo.
That's got to learn the lingo man.
Jeans at your mom's. Uh, yeah.
You were asking about my
pup play mask. Yeah. So,
well I was asking you about that mask.
You clarified that it was a pup play mass
that could have been a Halloween mask.
No, it doesn't look sexual.
No, it's just scared.
Scared. A couple of friends, that guy.
They're nice guys and we just hang
out and we put any of these guys,
like seven guys would getting cages.
We put tales in and then a guy
basically trains us, you know,
an outside one inside a dominant
one in or you got an outside,
he's got like a sick outside
owner outside the cage.
And he commands owner. Yeah, he's
an owner but it's not sexual. Again,
it's guys to hang out,
get to know each other and chill dues
that want to just relax bit like I got it.
I got a rock wilder mask at home.
I'd love to come play with you guys.
Rock Wilder and rock people at Maryland.
I used to hear these dudes
always call a German shepherd.
I heard a guy one time
called a German shepherd
problem. You got Doberman Germans,
Europe are all wrapped up wrong.
German
shepherd. You know, you have
such a unique accent and no,
it's like Mississippi or
something like that. But we were,
we were going over because Christina
doesn't know how to say certain things.
Could you tell me, I saw that you did
see that? How do you say that word?
The mini word. The full version.
Miniature. Miniature Mina. Sure.
Not Miniature.
It's not the queen's English
says miniature. What many? A Cha.
There was no queen over here. Number
one in jeans studio. There is,
is that,
I want to get that right.
Uh, here's a, here's a true test.
Go ahead. How do you say the,
the wax,
um,
that you color with a crayon versus
what else is the other option or crown
crown. Crown. Crown.
Yeah. I've never heard
that. Queen's English wears the crown,
but I'm fucking color when though crowds,
I've never heard. You've never heard
crowns that's really from crayon. I, well,
I did get crown a lot from kids in school,
like, Hey Ryan, do you have any crowns?
And I'm like, [inaudible] 64 of
them right there. I'll be like,
none of these are crowns.
Now pray on,
there's a word that I've been saying
and correctly that I just figured out.
It's dissociation,
not disassociation.
I've been saying it incorrectly
for my entire life. I'll be honest,
I don't even use that word.
M B, a t I t you know,
come back to combatitive.
I was saying combatitive instead
of combative like you're making,
you're going to make me confess on,
oh,
there's a word where I add that extra eye
and it's a all, what the fuck is that?
I can't say, Oh, I've got to
think of it. It'll come to me.
There's one where I add an I to and I'm
like, there's not. That's not there.
Fuck yeah. We wrote down
so bad. It is with ks,
plural.
People throw the s on the,
on the Nordstrom's to
always throw a Nordstrom.
Pronounce this word.
Ryan.
S. T. A. T. U. S. Status,
status. Status. Status. Status.
So some people do say status.
What about, what about Da ta data?
I see data on that. I
say data. I looked at it.
I think I'd go more data. Data. Yeah.
What about that school in
Indiana or also the, you know,
and otre regardless.
Just played a company Notredame yeah,
you said it right, right. It's
Notre Dame. Goddammit. Dom.
He's right. Yeah. I mean America is Notre
Dame. Notre Dame. I said no for dumb.
Especially if I'm hanging out with
like college football buddies.
Let's well damn game. Yeah.
They love it. They love it.
The fans here are really into the Alba.
That's a hardcore college
football fans love.
What are you guys wearing in your ears
right now that aren't the headphones I
have on my head that they're sitting here.
A Gucci is fucked, but these are nice.
These are inner ear ones. Yeah. Oh yeah.
I to put on my winter jacket
cause it's so cold. It's, yeah,
it's studio cold in here. Feels
the same shit. You're alert though.
I'm while I'm on point. Notre
Dame, Notre Dame, Notre Dame.
Um, have you ever had this where
you're talking to somebody,
you're having a normal conversation
and you ask them like a basic question,
like where are you from?
And then they have to close their eyes
and they're talking to you like this
asked me why her friend Christina,
where are you from? Well,
I was born in Windsor,
Ontario,
Canada and then I moved to La when I was,
that was five seconds where
if I see that my ass was gone
go. You ever see that? That's
your window to run? Yeah. Yeah.
You get that a lot
when you engage someone out of
kind of kindness and humanity,
like a toll booth guy or the guy
in the lobby and you're like,
how's it going man? He was
like, funny that you asked
start and he's like, yes, you're the first
guy that asked me that shit. All of it.
What do you want? Start with childhood
and you're like, what the fuck man,
here's my book. Open up to the chapter
one right there. We'll start out,
I'm going to put it on. It's like your
drivers that you keep texting me about.
They love to tell you wait,
goes dry. The same guy, that same guy,
but that's not that crazy
if it's the same company,
but at the same guy in different, the
first time he picks me up, he, this guy,
he picks me up and he goes, terminal
six today, sir. And I go, yeah,
it's a nice nice guy. He's wearing
a suit, big, you know, SUV,
like a suburban. And I start
emailing and then make a phone call.
And when I finally hang up,
I look up,
I realize we're pretty close
to the airport, so I go, oh,
or make a pretty good time.
He goes, cause I fucking
drive man. And I was
like, what? He goes, oh,
you know, you see this hands on 10 and
two kinds of shit. I don't fucking ran off
fucking drive, man. And I go,
yeah. And he's like, you know,
you see a lot of stupid shit out there.
I mean all the professionalism just come
on. He goes, you see lot of stupid shit.
Lot of times you wonder why is it stupid
shit happening and you pull up is cause
there's a stupid motherfucker in
the car. And I was like, yeah,
true. That is true. You can drop me out
here if you want. I feel like he's like,
he's like man ramping up.
And then
so I text both you guys about that guy.
Two weeks go by,
I see a walk out with my bag, go to the
airport. This time I see a sedan, Nice.
A nice car.
And
I had my bag and I'm like this,
this is the guy I think, you know,
I don't say anything. He's
like, how are you doing?
Put the bag in the car in the trunk
and I get in the back and he closes the
door. I go, this is a nice ride. And he
turns, he goes, I call this the pussy cat.
I swear to God immediately
car can I sit up front?
And then he, he starts turning around.
He goes, I ain't buy like this. You know,
everybody wave, it means shit. And I was
like, okay. It's like a nice, isn't it?
Is it something like it's a nice sedan.
Like I have Mercedes or nothing bigger.
More than that though.
No, no. Nothing flashy.
Draw like pussy wagon on the back
of fucking Quinten. They're not,
it's not sexy.
He fucking turns the car around.
We're going to the stop sign that
is 40 yards from our house. He goes,
I fucking a couple of older
bitches, I swear to God. And I go,
really? And he goes, yeah man.
Cause I got a theory like what is,
he goes women and they sixties.
It's like the pussy comes back to,
and I go, all right. And he's
like, he's like, yeah man,
these won't fuck want, fuck,
want to fuck. And I go, cool. He
goes, the body sometimes tight,
but they can't hide that face man.
I'll fucking rank lives.
Don't look them in the
eye. And I go, okay,
how about [inaudible] work?
He starts, you know, he's uh,
he's like, yeah, amazing. I
got this other bitch. She,
she's a tease though, you know, she'll
play with my Dick and uh, you know,
fuck around, smoke something, drink
something. But then I'm just trying to,
I'm trying to fuck her. She'll say she
has to go home. I told her, I said,
I ain't got no guy. I've got no time
for that shit because when this digging,
it's ready to go, man. And then it's like,
how would you say he was probably in
his sixties too late fifties he's like
talking about the old [inaudible].
So we're in the car business. He
just citizen. How old are you? 60
we're like quiet for a minute.
And I'm like, all right. You know,
just kind of like having
one of those moments.
He told me this crazy story and
I'm just quiet and he goes and my,
you ever notice when you don't come,
how that'll fuck with bitches mind?
Oh my God. Like I don't have that
problem. Yeah, right. I'm like,
yeah, but that's, that's his
conversation and then we put the,
he's like, have a nice flight.
So crazy Tommy. I know. What
did you say to all that?
I was just laughing and like, or I
would, did you record any of it? No.
I thought about it then I felt this
audio. I know I wanted some audio. He um,
I'm sure I'm going to get him again.
I'm sure they're going to,
if the guys come twice, it's like, it
feels like he came twice last night.
He gives him old,
old bitches.
I don't know if he'd go get him a good,
he's always told me he sounds like
he's just jog. I don't like this shit.
He told me that and I was like,
that's cool. The guy. Yeah,
the guy that's got your life in his hands
and the wheels on ain't give a fuck.
What? He was like, God, I fuck all
that to two shit. All these airbags,
bags and shit, man. I didn't have
any of that when I was a kid.
Let's see what this thing is.
Ready to dive right into a semi.
Like it's all right when that man,
he's a wild dude.
I don't give a fuck. I'm not, tonight
I'm going to talk for by trade, by trade.
He's a
second Manco but you have
a knack for psycho drivers.
Remember the guy they used to pick us
up and we lived in Korea town. Yes.
He liked to smoke crack.
I talked about that dude in a special.
How did you find out or drop them?
I like to smoke or there were
usually actually pretty good.
I was going to say they're pretty open.
This dude he ran,
I mean this is when like,
you know,
this was like the best option for us at
the time for an airport ride because a
crack at this,
well y'all come long ways to studio genes.
So what is that?
I get a ride like a car
service from crack drivers.
So right here guys,
I'm proud of you
guys,
studio g but if you have the,
if you need to get to the airport and
like in these are flights for like our
middle weeks and you know like yeah,
start starting to do no money.
So he would be, he was for a long time,
he was reliable cause I'd be like,
I have a flight at 8:00 AM and I need to
get picked on. He says, right. Yeah. Um,
and I need to get picked up at like six
30 or whatever. And he would be like,
I'll be there. I'll be up.
Do you know why though?
Because he'd already been up partying.
It was up a neighbor cause that's
where he bought crack. That, that,
that neighborhood's really Latino and he
won't say the name of the street that I
remember. Carondelet yeah, that's right.
That name has stuck with me for some,
it's such a weird Carondelet.
It's actually, I think you
could name someone that,
yeah,
no,
you could
maybe like use my girlfriend
Karen sounds like a first team.
All ACC safety or something.
The little pockets right then Carondelet
he'll shake. It's like corner.
Uh,
one of the,
he drove and he was like,
I like, I like these girls.
Then we pulled up and there
were like young Latin girl.
He's creeping up next to him because
we were pulling the stop sign he can,
cause I liked these. He goes, I love the
little brown ones, man. I was like, okay.
And he was in his sixties,
you know, he's like, oh,
I like these little brown ones. Man.
I'm really like, okay. And then, yeah,
a one time he was a,
he's like, you want to,
you want to hit like as of what we'd like,
he's still driving.
But first I thought
you're going to say crack
and drive us to the airport.
He get high as he was driving us running
the car service and never asked once if
you're okay with that or the smoker.
And he was like, I mean, he's like,
are you cool or what? You know? And
I was like, yeah, don't be a pussy.
Then he's like, this shit. You know
from like him talking about weed,
I'm like, yeah, I'm cool with weed.
And he was like,
well,
it really misses the fucking hardcore
stuff and talking about smoking crack,
I was like, really? Like you
do that? He's like, I mean,
every once in a while I'll do
all the time. So I was like,
oh, you still, he's like,
I dabble. You know when it's time to
like have some fun, you know, I'll,
I'll fucking,
I like to just freak myself.
I remember he told me that I like
to get real high. Just freak out.
Looked through the people
look likes. Oh I remember.
Yeah. We were like,
like about, I said, cause I, I'm like,
what do you like about smoking crack?
What do you enjoy? And he said, I, I get
real paranoid and freaked out. And I,
I like to look out to
people and see his coming.
I'm like terrible until this moment.
I've never even considered
the fact of just the sheer volume of
humans on this planet at any given point.
The billions of people,
a percentage of them probably do like
to be scared and freaked the fuck out.
And it makes sense. Maybe that's what,
maybe that's what the crack addicts are,
that percentage of people that really
have a high, tall joy that yeah.
But also I have a high tolerance for weed,
but also I'm a weed smoker.
I would smoke my weed
of good. Uh, you know,
probably two minutes after I dropped y'all
off, I wouldn't be smoking weed alive.
No, no, no. What I'm saying is this
though, do you ever have, you did,
does the experience exists for you where
you've gotten too high and you're a
little paranoid? Yeah. So one of my
friends is a daily smoker. You pee,
you know people who have like
contraptions, like you know,
you put this volcano thing
and here wait to all of it,
this motherfucker and there's like
shovels and all kinds of,
what are you doing?
It's always the newest way to get,
and then the weed is never just weed.
It's like there's crystals and they said
this to the moon and they brought it
back and it's got all types of Shit.
And then you know,
it was in the rain forest and you're like,
all right man. It's like you smell it.
You're like this unbelievable looks crazy.
So this dude,
I smoked a little bit and I go,
yeah man, I, I'm way too high.
I'm kind of freaked out. And he's
like, yeah, me too. And I go, I go,
don't you smoke every day? He's
like, I do this every day. I get,
I get to that like paranoid
freaked out part. And I go,
why don't you hate it? He goes, yeah,
but then I liked going back there too,
you know?
So like I,
I hate it while I'm this freaked out
and then I go back and I do it again.
So he likes to live in that anxious state.
Yeah.
Can I tell you say I get it now, now
that I think of it, cause you know,
I'm just thinking about what
you were saying like, you know,
were here like done too much acid and
you're like, oh I got to hold it together.
Do this. Got It. Okay. But
whenever you do too many drugs,
you have to hold it together and
you're just trying to hold together.
And it's like all your focus
is in holding it together.
And there's something freeing about that.
It's like when people rock climb
or do something dangerous, right?
You're so present because you're just
trying to hold your shit together.
You're in survival and when you're in
survival, you're not thinking about bills,
your divorce. It's a good point.
The children, you're ignoring
whatever to smart things today.
It's crazy.
Do I get a star? Yeah. Well, you have
this chart. I'm gonna get you a new hat.
The hat comic, right? Yeah.
I've got loads of, Oh shit.
You got to put on one of these toboggans
not what people call them. Beanies. Yeah,
she's really cold. Yeah. You look
good in a beanie, Christina. Yeah.
Let me try it out. I gotta get a
y on h one. I was going to say,
do you guys sell those cars?
You should ours. Oh wait.
You'll learn why you got to show you.
I've got to show you this.
So this was where I'm watching
over. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So
there's, uh, this, this, uh,
these twins were on in Australia on
Australian TV. I'm a twin. I should know.
Check this out. They're mixed race twins.
I always forget that. I'm not sure.
These are twins.
At listen to
read science,
you got to listen to the,
I've read sign the anchor, like, just
clearly listened to what they say. Okay,
go ahead.
One of the sisters is obviously bike.
Briova is wide.
The Alma twins come from a
mixed race family in the UK.
Maria has taken off to her half Jamaican
mom with dark skin and Brown eyes and
curly dark hair, but Lucy got her dad's
fair skin. Good on it along with straight.
Look at the guy. He's like, I said,
the way Mike Myers snapped
his head when Kanye said,
George Bush doesn't care about black
people. He was like, wait a second.
This is live right now.
I'm stuck with that
math labs almost shot off.
He said,
your wife, congratulations on you.
Good on you got the white stuff.
You got the good stuff,
by the way,
very observant. I watch down here.
That went from 24 degrees, 25 degrees.
It's almost the same temperature
in this God damn studio right now.
Wait,
let's hear it again
and is there please tell me some why
I reacted out of that. What's that?
One of these girls say anything
about it? No. No. Wow. That's
terrible. They're like,
we hear it. All the sisters,
twins turning heads.
This dude turns his mother fucker.
He does.
Oh,
my twins come from a mixed race because
look at the guy's taken off to her half
Jamaican mom, dark skin and
Brown eyes and curly dark hair.
But Lucy got her dad's first skin good
on it along with Oh, unbelievable.
And she says dark skin. She goes down
and tell him what she says that. But she,
no, no. Yeah, I like your restaurant.
Is this Australian,
I'm assuming? Yes. Yeah. Do
you guys really an accent
again? That was really good.
Right? Go ahead. The other twin got, uh,
her father's fast skin
and complexion and uh,
ah,
Gotcha.
Father's fair skin and
complexion and supremacy.
Yes.
She does go like,
and then the other guy got the God stop.
So sorry for you.
But her twin sister got,
oh, the goodness of the white.
I felt like a say. Yeah,
but don't worry. The other sister was
not as unfortunate. She got the whites,
the whites.
How old is this? I don't know what
you'll do with that red hat, but oh well.
It's unreal. My life. Fantastic.
I've read a good honor.
Like I said,
science and um,
you can actually have two kids from
two different dads who are twins.
Like there's a,
this is what I read.
There's a small window where you could
actually impregnate a lady twice,
two different people and they come out
the same day, everything like this.
And by definition you're twins because
you're in there at the same time and
everything. Sure. But it
doesn't necessarily mean
biologically. That's the same.
That's a real hoe though, right there,
right. She's, it could be, well,
it's a real slot. That one, you know,
unfortunately gave a child dark skin,
but hey, she made up for it. Yeah.
Probably had sex the next day to
balance it out. Yeah, that's true.
It's been a three slides.
Could have been a threesome.
That could have been Chelsea lately.
Once we did a story where a woman had
to uterus to uterus and both of them was
impregnated. Come on by two
different daddies too, I think. Yeah.
And you can and then have both those
babies. Yeah. Out of your pussy. Wow.
Out of your mind. Not My boss. How do
you pussy hole. Hey, by the way, uh,
I love the bird made you think
of anything. Uh, before I forget,
we have the official,
your mom's house Fart Mike.
So if you feel as what you have to
fart during the show, let me know.
I'll turn it on. You have to turn it
on and then you go ahead and park.
I kind of feel like I was an inspiration.
Did I not tell you guys you should have
a fart Mike or fart on the mic or you
should record it or some maybe not
take credit for something. Okay, well,
oh sure. Okay. Um, so I can
just get up and grab that.
Oh boy. Oh, you have to, you
have to power it up. Yeah.
You wouldn't want to miss that.
She's real excited about,
give me a five minute heads
up if you've got a power. Um,
I feel good. I don't have any
guest speaking of farts. Let's, uh,
check out this. Check out.
This already start off.
It's already started off.
Good. Check this out.
No, I shouldn't eat so much, baby.
Why is you could get into me. Yeah.
Cool.
You know,
seems like that something's
going to happen, you know,
doesn't it feel like it's about
something's about to happen?
Something like if I'm her,
I'm moving,
right?
Oh No.
Rush to boot and they're giddy up.
Bite my head. Okay, I'm ready.
What is going on with you guys?
Must know she is not been put our mouth.
No she's not.
I thought he was gonna Fart.
I thought he was going to Fart and
accidentally shit all over her.
That's where I'm at. Let's see what
happens. Well, were at your mom's house.
That ain't happened.
Right.
And her full face Co.
Oh my God. What is happening?
You know what's interesting?
We fart on our dogs' heads and one of
them does not like it and the other one
does is again, yeah, I want to
make sure I see this correctly.
That's in her mouth. That's
gold. That's gold veins, right?
Lack of respect is what that is for
yourself. She put herself back there.
He didn't make it.
He wouldn't even ask.
That was her.
Yeah.
That's how you come. Okay. I mean
it's rare that a woman
enjoys the vets with Dessa.
What stands out the most is that like you,
I mean if that's the other
way around you're like, Yep,
there's just another sick
fucking guy. Right? Like it's
just, there's just endless,
one thing we've learned doing this show,
there's an endless amount of sick
fucking guy, man willing to do anything.
But when women do it, it definitely stands
out more. It's special. It is special.
It is spelled, she's a neat trick. She is,
hey, she's making this guy really happy.
It gets to go baby. I got a fart about,
she was like, well hold up, hold on.
Don't waste that shit. And then she
gets him positioned face in his,
told him to hold. Hang on real
quick man, don't let that loose.
I want all of that one of those
like bite his lower lip kind of like
she was all,
that's what I like.
God Damn Hillary Clinton
never did that to me.
No, never did that to me during that. I've
got the burps but not the farts today.
Yeah, that's a tough one for me. Cause
you could be the best woman in the world.
But if you were like, if
you were everything. Yeah,
I mean a good person to my daughter.
Great to me.
I shouldn't say great to everybody. My
daughter included. Not just good to her,
great to me,
but if everything checked off and
you were like, I'm a millionaire,
you don't ever have to work again. I
couldn't kiss you. I couldn't. I'm sorry.
What do you mean?
I could know that the one hang up
of all the shit on the list is like,
I just like you to Fart in my
mouth. I would be like, I can't,
that's a deal breaker for you.
I have to disagree with you.
Pass you pass.
I does it have to be done on
video or can be some shit private.
Whatever needs worried.
She's like,
don't you go fucking wasting those
God damn farts and she's not there.
And then when you fart she fingers.
I'll tell you what. Here's what, here's
what's good. I'm already entertaining it.
Yeah, that is so nasty. I couldn't think
about, you've got my asshole there. You,
I hope Hillary Clinton. That's me.
That's right. I left you that message.
Clinton eight my asshole.
That was back when I was smoking and
drinking whiskey row when I was in my
sixties the way back to this. So this is
awesome. This angel comes into your life.
Yeah. And she does
everything right. Right.
Everything money to like unlimited
money. I don't even have to worry, honey,
you don't have to work. Come
here and pocket left your
daughter. She likes to be,
she's like, I love the
ravens. I want to go to games.
I just want to you a box about your
box. Let's have crab cakes. She's,
you know, she's just the best. You
just love everything about her.
And then she's like, just fart in my
mouth. You know? Not even every day,
every other day. I mean,
look, it will be tough.
It's all I can think about it.
That's that one thing is
all I can think about.
Not everything else
you just listed at all.
Like we'd be flying to a
ravens game and I'd be like,
I haven't kissed this woman right here
and I just farted in her mouth last night.
I don't know. I don't think I could
do that. I think you get over it.
I don't think I can mentally get
paid. I would try. Here's the thing,
I don't that I have the stomach.
Okay, I hear what you're saying. That
that part is kind of nasty. The the shit,
the FARC particles and are barely nasty
sparely now I agree is barely Nancy.
You can fart through the fabric of your
genes and that way the particles don't
get in her mouth of poop. But, but
here's my thought. In terms of fetishes,
he's like, Huh, let's,
and in terms of fetishes,
it's a really easy one to accommodate.
You're not really actively doing magic
set for what you normally would be doing.
You, you would normally fart anyways.
She's just enjoying what you normally do.
It's kind of a blessing in the sky.
You have, and always have
had a way with me, Christina.
So I'm going to entertain it and say,
okay,
you're not 100% wrong because it's not
me that's getting the fart in my mouth.
I am delivering the Fart.
And when you say it like that,
I might be able to power pastor for
a few months. But what if you fart?
You have to fart through.
Could you imagine if I brought her over
and you didn't know anything and then
when we broke up your guys will be like,
why did you guys split? I'd be like,
number one,
I just can't fart in her mouth anymore.
That's what she's doing.
Any woman wanted that? I
don't. I couldn't get past it.
I could seriously, is that
the deal breaker? I just,
why wouldn't know that? Like I
don't have done that. By the way,
I've never had that
precedent set where I'm like,
I'm not going to date any woman that ever.
This is the first time it's ever been
asked to me and it's the first time it's
ever, well, let them present
threshold.
What if she insisted on wearing this
dog mask when during your lovemaking,
is that a deal? Every time,
every time it sort of thing.
That's a deal breaker. She wears it.
That's a deal breaker every time.
What do you, how do you see it? What about
role playing? What if she's just like,
you know, just call me like a
Puerto Rican slot or something.
But she's white,
you know,
like she has some type of like race play
fantasy or something. What if she, yeah,
and it's like horribly racially
offensive for you. I actually was,
I had that one time what I was with,
I was dating a black girl who wanted me
to talk to play that kind of shit and
bed and I was like,
nope, really? No, no way.
She said call me names, yes.
Offensive names. And I was like,
no,
like Carondelet
I was like, I'll go
Carondelet that is it. Okay.
Just give me a ballpark.
It was the n word.
One of those was other ones
were just other horrible
just things. And I was like,
I can't, couldn't get past the n
word, so I don't even remember what
turns me off
like that.
But she wasn't saying it to
say it does not turn me on.
So she was like,
call me that.
That was one of the things and just
other just filthy, nasty, horrible shit.
And I was like, I'm good.
Filthy by the way. Uh,
the one who the one,
no,
they the girl who stayed at your house
and like know that that crazy girl that
was not her one,
that was an email and it was all because
of an email you and I exchanged and she
got my password and read that email that
you and I exchange and that's why she
got mad because they're totally different.
Girl is a totally different girl is not
that at all. But um, I met this girl,
she ended up staying
at my place one night.
I left ahead of her and just was like,
whatever.
And she hacked my password on my computer
and just went through emails and saw
one that you and I had said and it
was nothing. It was a simple joke. Um,
and I really don't remember what it
was, but she was just like, fuck you.
How dare you talk about me like that.
He's clearly hack my password.
So I changed it and I was like,
leave me alone. I'll leave you alone.
And that was it. But it really
wasn't anything terribly offensive.
She just was pissed that
we were talking about her.
What kind of horrible things to the
other lady want you to say? Go ahead.
The one we were already talking about,
she's like,
call me the n word as we're doing it.
I mean like filthy.
You were that you up. How does she set
you up for the race? She's like daughter,
does she go like, wait, does she
listen to this show your daughter? No,
she will tell you. That's
true. How does she set you up?
Like you guys are, is it like
you're making out for a while? Well,
if it was set up this way,
it wasn't like this one time
gradually got to getting crazier.
Like it was,
there was one time where she was staring
me in the face so much and we were,
we were done.
I said to her,
I feel like you wanted me
to call you a bitch. And she
goes, I did. And I was like,
Holy Shit. And that's
where it started. Like,
she kept getting at it like
call me names and I was like,
I'm not going to fuck us
cause if I'm wrong, uh,
I mean that is not going
to be a good thing. Sure.
But who knew how wrong I was allowed to
be and they do it. But I'm saying did,
did the next time when it did it come
up again like in the heat of pull them
bitch just became a thing cause I didn't
have a problem calling. Oh really?
Whatever. If that's, I don't
mind bitch. But yeah. Um,
for that slot, that stuff, if she
was okay with that, I'm like, oh,
that's your thing. That's fine. You're
requesting it. But so you were going,
you're going along with that part of yeah,
we'll get a little bit.
And then it got to like, when the request
came in for like, for the tip top,
was it,
was it in like are you like naked or
is it like you're just having dinner?
She's like, Hey, by the way at
night, what do you step it up?
I think they were at Shakey's.
Yeah.
Yeah. Uh, I really don't remember,
but I would probably say
at that point we were just,
I mean we're probably even at that point
like still close on just making out
talking and stuff like that and then she
started like, you know, and I was like,
yeah, let me just stop going. That's
interesting cause like you can generally,
yeah.
Yeah. I mean can't eat generally
gauge when someone is like game,
like you know what I'm saying?
Like it's kind of bad on her to not gay
that maybe you weren't comfortable with
that kind of stuff. I don't
know. It's an odd choice.
It's an odd choice.
It's definitely an odd choice for good.
It would've been amazing if she had said,
what'd you do that? And you're like,
I've been waiting the whole time
but only at the grocery store.
[inaudible]
thank God you asked man. I was just
like, I still to this day that's a,
this the same graph said this
before on stage and everything.
This is the same girl that when we first
had sex she said out loud to herself,
but way out loud. I can't believe
I just slept with a white guy.
I'm loud. Yeah. This is hilarious to me.
I laughed so fucking hard. I was like,
that is great. And then it
progressed and I was like, that is,
this is turn not great here guys. That's
what I fuck. I never heard this story.
I forgot about it until you, uh,
played this, this romance here.
Get me all fired up here. And
a studio. Jean's mother. Oh,
before, before we, I don't, I don't want
to forget about it. The new podcast.
It's called the honeydew.
Yeah, the honeydew. Uh, you
can subscribe now. You can,
you can start listening to it.
It's a big group.
You can get a prescription
right now. Um, audio,
audio is going to start coming
out on Mondays, right? Yeah.
So we're going to move things around.
Currently right now
through January audio only
until we get in the studio
and do video is Wednesday.
Every Wednesday through January,
we hit February and we
officially get in the studio.
We're going to slide audio to Monday,
video to Tuesday. Okay, perfect.
And the studio or the video you can
watch here on the y youtube channel.
Um, you're going to be over
on this set here. Studio.
What's that set to set to set B?
Yeah,
I'm also native.
Can you jump on for one second?
You set up a separate, uh,
channel for clips, right?
So now people can subscribe to what is
the youtube.com/your mom's house clips
and that's like highlights and things
like that of all the shows that we'll be
putting out from the main channel.
So full episodes on the main channel,
which is the one you're
currently subscribed to and
have the clips channel is
where all the highlights are going.
So if you want a watch,
like the three minute thing or the
clip or like the highlight of this,
this call is animation or whatever,
those will all be on the clips channel.
Full episodes only will be on the main,
correct.
Now can I ask a question as an
audience member and fan as well.
So we will have one,
your mom's house youtube page where
all uh, shows will live. That's right.
And then a separate completely
clips from all shows. Yes. As well.
Yeah. That's great. Yeah. So you
can, you can just, you'll get,
you'll get clips from all these shows.
Um,
so in February you can look
forward to watching the show.
I'm the honeydew on Tuesdays,
right.
Your Mom's House Wednesdays,
Dr Drew Fridays. Um,
I'm not sure about there's another show
or two. We'll know soon, whatever. Um,
but honey do, you did do the first
one I did with, uh, Josh, he was my,
he, so I'd like to have a rotating
cohost at times that I vibe with the,
I just think also I'd like to have promote
and come on and laugh with. But, um,
yeah, he was the co host
for that. Basically,
I introduced myself to anyone who
doesn't know what the fuck I am,
which is pretty much as you did
the crappies for years. Yeah.
And reintroduce myself and I don't
know that I've completely got,
I don't think I ever really got into my
story that deep on crab feast I think I
did on other podcasts.
Um,
and it got a lot of a really good,
um,
response and reviews and even Karen
Kogarah for my favorite murder,
gave it a shout out and
it was a huge bump. Yeah.
So very excited for the things
ahead and to be here in a studio,
jeans at your mom's house and
Christina, have you been, I'm stoked.
I really want you to be,
once we get cameras up,
I really want you to be like number one,
if you can do it,
we got to talk about you and
I always talk about it anyway.
Might as well just record it for
a fucking change. That'd be great.
The premise is of honey
do for those of you don't.
So the premise of the honey
do is just highlighting and
laughing at the low lights of life.
Anytime you've ever felt
thrown away or not good enough.
Or it could be a life story,
it could be an individual story.
Maybe it's a divorce or a,
a firing from a job or whatever.
But it's all about the negative in life
and laughing in the face of it and,
and coming out on the other side.
And looking back and being like, God,
I remember when I thought that shit was
the worst and thank God that happened.
And why is it called honey deal?
It's called the honeydew because a,
I was eating one night and,
and I didn't eat the honeydew out of my
fruit cup because I never eat the honey
do out of my fruit cup and I don't have
a serious like hate for honey do I just
don't fuck with the honeydew.
And then when I walked out I saw it
everywhere on the tables and I was like,
oh I'm a honeydew.
I've been thrown away time after
time and break people's hearts.
I wanted to know.
I want to laugh at that shit cause it's,
it's empowering and it's therapy and
it's helpful, sweet and delicious.
If you get a good one, if you get a
good one, there's nothing wrong with it.
But since then I had a fruit
cup yesterday. I've tweeted it.
They didn't even bother with
the fucking honey do there.
What do we wasted our money on that shit
for. People been tweeting at me like,
hey, here's the fruit platter left at
my work and it's like three pieces of
cantaloupe and honey dew on a bed
of lettuce. Someone's, I said,
who the fuck's putting fruit on lettuce?
I like cantaloupe but not the honey.
I do too.
I like cantaloupe.
There's a small percentage of
people that do like honey do.
Just like there's a small percentage of
people that want farts in their fucking
mouth from their loved ones. So very
small. The honeydew is the fart.
That's right. By the way, it's
that woman of the fruit world.
Let me put a call out.
One time we put a fart call out to guys
who have the fart fetish cause we were
like, come on like are you for real?
And these guys wrote in who really?
They're like,
yeah and they explained their whole thing.
I just want to put a call out.
If there's any women out there with
the with do they really want you to
definitely going to
want to hear from them.
You're going to hear from them the one,
it's like shame her.
She's, well no, here's the
specifications. It's not like,
do you like it when your Hubby farts? Are
you around? That's what I want to know.
Do you want to put your mouth up on it?
It's a thing for you.
It's one thing that Dutch oven somebody,
it's another thing to just put the shit
right in the oven. You know what I mean?
Like God, Oh God, it makes
my stomach turn. Uh, by the
way, do you want to give him,
we were discussing before.
Sure.
What you would do if you
could eat anything and never,
Tom and I had this discussion
a while back. You know,
there's a point where you turn 40 or even
your late thirties where you can't eat
shit. Bass for me, like early
thirties. But yeah, go ahead.
Like you just can't fucking eat the
way you did. And it's a bummer. Like,
now we have the soda at the
House, like Stevia, Shit.
Like you can't even drink a soda
because you're going to get fucking bad.
So I was like,
what would you do in order to be able to
eat whatever you wanted and never gain
weight?
Like what would you give up?
And so we start running through
this stuff and I was like, Tom,
would you give up a tooth just missing
one tooth, but you can eat anything?
Hell No. She was like, what
about one of these bags,
grandma teeth back here didn't bother
back. Whatever I want and never gain.
I was like, yeah, yeah, that's a good
deal. And that tooth Doug brought,
it's already gone. You save them money
all around. It's a win win. There you go.
So we all agree that we'd lose a tooth.
He's easy. What's the next one? Okay. Uh,
would you live in Nebraska? Okay.
And here's the stipulation. I know.
Well, I'll say, here's my answer.
This is what I look like right now.
I don't live in Nebraska.
I'd rather just look like this.
But here's the thing, you, you live in
Nebraska. Nine months out of the year,
you're allowed to travel.
You can travel for catch spring training,
go eat whatever I want.
I was somewhere else.
But you're eating everything
you want in Nebraska.
Keep in mind so you know
it's American gravy and shit.
Jury. Oh, you do as
gravy. Mashed potatoes,
like Vietnamese food, pot
roast, garbage. I can't, Shit.
One time I made a mistake. Somebody
invited me over for dinner. I was like,
make whatever you want.
And they were like,
I'm going to make pot roast and
carrots. And I was like, I'm not coming.
That's the one thing I probably should
have fuck up. Put on my list. Boiled. No,
I would not do that. I wouldn't
live in Nebraska. No. Even Omaha.
Well, no. Yeah. Again,
this is what I look like.
I live in Los Angeles.
If the choice is to stay looking
like this in La, I'll fake it.
I'd keep these extra 20 pounds on me.
That Katie's extra 40 live out here.
Yeah.
You need that in Nebraska.
Those nine must be cold in Nebraska.
You're skinny like you're a Nebraska 10
but what if you in your mind are like,
I want to be fat, I want to be fat.
Then stay where you want. Exactly. Yeah,
that's true. No, you're right. Okay,
so we all agree we're not going to
fuck Nebraska. That's right. Okay.
What'd you sleep in the dog crate with
the dogs at night like you know I put
bitsy and fee for then goodnight Tommy.
And you go in the crane and just get
to eat what I want. Nothing. I'm good.
I'm good on that.
Will you clean up crime scenes like nope.
Like really horrific, brutal
crime scenes. There's a,
then you can eat whatever you
want. Yes. I wouldn't take that.
Can I tell you a story? No, you wouldn't.
You would be vomiting every, everywhere.
Every time will be some new shit.
Like an eyeball on a wall up here.
You're like, I'd seen that shit.
This attitude of like,
no problem is such bullshit.
Then I can come home and eat
lasagna and eat my feelings away.
You would not even make it. You wouldn't.
You would be so physically though. Yes.
I feel like I got it. Just a woman
torn open, like come desensitized.
Know what you're talking about.
Yeah. Become fucked up. Call.
Not desensitized,
but think how skinny I'd be in hot to who?
The dead people are looking at
you every day. They don't need me.
They can't even say, Hey, you look nice
lady. You know what? We get my, Oh,
I'm over there. I like it here in
Lincoln. You look, are you with Lincoln?
10 girl. All right. Well would you sleep
on a dog crate with my dogs? Hell No.
No one's dog or a dog
house. No, that's not easy.
What about pooping outside?
Like my dogs every time.
Every time you have to beat
your opponents. Yeah, a
no problem. Not a problem.
Man's great IP outside. Last
night, a few times I peed outside.
We were in the backyard.
Yeah, having a cigar.
You pissed in my backyard a
number of times. Your boy,
what do you think your boys are
going to be paying? No, I know,
but did the exam and then birthday too.
Great.
He drops his pants to his ankles
to take a look like a child. Yeah.
I'll show you your toddler. Um, so I,
so you would pee and poo in my backyard.
No problem. I do that even if
I look like this. Look. Yeah.
Cause that's, Oh my God. My
friend did that at though.
We went to a ravens game
match the urinals for the men.
There's like a lie to 10
deep at every one of them.
Bob Buddy walked up and dropped his pants.
There's God,
they have ankles like birth did right
there at the front of everybody just peed.
I just could, I could not stop
laughing. I was like, what?
There's a hundred fucking feet
one. Okay. Give three kids.
What if, what if you can eat anything
you want, but every time you,
you start a show, a standup show,
okay. You just subtly say Heil Hitler.
My Name's Ryan.
No,
you mean the one time I get to say that
I get the look like what I want for the
rest of them.
I'm good.
But what if you got to say it on talk
shows and stuff? Yeah, no, no, no.
I know I'm good on that. Oh, I'll
go 300 pounds. I ever do that shit.
I'll be like, wheel me out.
They said I'm ready. Alright.
What if you just have
to work a Heil Hitler
in conversation? You don't have
to start with, he used to be like,
you just have to find a way to work it
in that organic. You would do that. Yeah.
Yeah, you would. I'd be like, you know,
funny thing Ryan and I'm studying the
Holocaust Heil Hitler and a funny thing
they used to say and I would work.
Do you want to do that?
That's easy. I feel like that blue band
so far, shitting and trusting in your, uh,
what'd you do? That one, and it is just
Jewish. Just squeeze in a Heil Hitler,
but to be able to eat anything you
want and never gain weight. Ooh.
And all I gotta do is say,
how is it that you have
to find a way to say hi.
It was gotta to be like, Hi Hitler
like that. Hi. Hi. That's a high,
that's a friendly, hello.
Yeah. Oh Dude, dude,
I saw a Chinese Hitler.
I saw,
I swear to God, I can't
believe I, I don't remember
this when I was in San
Francisco over the weekend. Uh,
amazing by the way. Always amazing,
amazing shows. I'm walking down a grant.
Yeah. Chinatown. Yeah.
There is a dude who like
probably in his thirties,
he had his hair pulled
back into like a man bun.
He's wearing like a throwback
49 or starter jacket.
And he had a Hitler stash.
I was like, this guy is,
and he was walking with such confidence.
He was like,
I dare you to point out that I
have a start. I'm Chinese wearing a
jacket and 88 started jack.
He had boots on God,
a boots, military boots.
Not like, no, no, no.
He had like a, I don't know, like,
you know Staci boots, like cool.
The cool guy boots. I don't what the
fuck you would call him? Martin's? No,
not doc Martins, but they were like,
uh, like Johnny Depp would wear. Yeah,
like that kind of boot. Right.
And then, so then, and then jeans,
throw back starters, 40 niners
jacket. You sure it was on our logo,
not a Nazi symbol and that you fuck
close up word. I mean a deliberate, oh,
he walked right by us to be deliberately,
dude. Yeah. It's only deliberate.
Your whole life's like I dare someone
to say some shit to me right now.
It's not like you can't,
that's where I,
that's where I thought
you were going to go.
I thought you're going to ask if I
would shave the stash like that. No,
I wouldn't do any of that to eat whatever
you want and never so far I will shit
and Piss in your yard. That's where I'm
at so far. I'm sure you have more common.
What if? Can you just say
the n word to ones? No.
Once a day
you have to work.
Even though your podcast,
you will all,
it will be me alone on that fucking desk
filling the whole God damn thing goes.
I feel like,
is she on her knees about do a gang bang?
It's like 10 black guys
pausing to have a conversation.
Maybe I should tip toe lightly and say
n word weed out this so it's just going
to be seven of you then.
Okay,
so you wouldn't do that either?
Hell No. No. What'd you know?
You would know your life is ruined.
The funny thing is to ask someone
like, Hey, would you ruin your life?
Oh you wouldn't.
That's weird.
Now you are a twin brother. Do you
think he believe you? If you told him
that you can come in forest routes
for, okay, I'm, I'm being
serious. I know you are.
Okay.
You smoke meth with your brother.
You have to do this once in your life
and you can eat whatever you want and
never gain weight.
This is a one time
you smoke meth with your brother.
You masturbate and you ejaculate in four
strokes and then he pulls his penis out
and he does the same
and that's it.
That's all you do.
But you can eat wherever you
want to watch each other do that.
I'll smoke meth with him once,
but as the keep my dick in my pants.
You wouldn't do that just
once. No. Why not? We shared.
We shared a room growing up, so I'm sure
we were doing it around it. Yeah, I know.
I was getting my fix and and a
bathroom and everywhere else. Yeah.
Never once said,
I'll walk in the bedroom,
but you're just going
to jerk this real quick.
Why don't you get out of here and play
some double dribble real quick and I'll
come back.
Switch.
Call me fucking controllers in front
of your brothers. I would not know.
I'm sure he's listening right now.
Disappointed in Delaware, but uh,
I wouldn't do that though.
All right.
Serve yourself pretty sad for a square.
What'd you do that in front
of one of your sisters?
Todd's different that I
bought your dad? Yeah. Okay.
How about this?
Would you watch your dad come four
strokes and then you can eat whatever you
want. If you could stand up
there and be able to guess,
it's going to say I'd never be able to
keep it down ever. I think of my face.
Yeah. That is so traumatic though,
to see your dad. Oh, to me,
I couldn't even imagine. I don't think
you could eat. No, no, you're not eating.
That's why he'd stay skinny.
That's trauma, trauma and stress.
The rest of your life like I
can't eat. All right. Um, look,
I want to make sure people know it's the
honeydew. You can subscribe right now.
I was organic. Thank you.
Want to get it wrong?
You wouldn't charge him
in front of your father.
Let's just to remind everybody that
takes the honeydew podcast.com.
I'm Ryan sickler on all social media.
The first plug I've ever had.
It's the worst slash best, I gotta
be honest. It's studio genes.
What have your studio g
yes. Oh my God. I'm very,
I'm very excited for the,
the what the future holds here at
the studio genes. Your mom's house.
Yes. I'll be doing the honey do
podcast and studio B. So exciting.
I'm very excited. I think it's a, it's
a really good line for you to be in.
I think you're going to have a really
interesting perspective on stuff.
I hope so. We'll see. Um, I, you know,
I'm nervous. I'm starting all over again.
It's you get out of your
comfort zone, which I like
and that feels good. But also,
you know, there's so
much that goes, you know,
there's so much that goes into
starting something new and an ending,
something you've been
doing for such a long time.
So I'm very excited and I
really appreciate you guys
making me a part of the
family members. You're always can
wait to shit and Piss in your yard.
I'm doing that for free and you
gotta check off of your brother and,
and we'll picture your dad doing
it. Oh God. So the show's about
every
Monday and then two,
the vignette beginning in February,
February.
Currently audio on Wednesday.
You will get audio Monday
video Tuesday in February.
Wow.
That's, it will be a we back momentarily.
Thank sickle cell. Thank you guys.
And we're back.
We ate unfortunately,
wasted a couple farts in the
green room here in the lobby,
but who knows,
maybe some magical happen.
That was pretty impressive.
You just give us the heads up.
We got to say who's here
are our final guest for today's
episode is the great and drew Santina.
Thank you. Yay. Thank you. I
might fart. You might fart.
We have an apartment if I have to.
You'll just pass it over here.
That's so great that you guys
thought of everything at the studio.
Well if nothing else,
she was like,
there's no way we're moving to a new
space and not getting apart my priority by
the way off. So if you feel it,
you got to grab it, turn it on.
It's like a loft. There was no
wind sock on there either. No,
I didn't really want to get in there.
The fart Mike is ironically what every
microphone is that any comedy club I've
ever played.
How disgusting that does a microphone.
So I dunno what comics set it,
but it made me laugh so hard.
Someone we were at the Improv and someone
was onstage like like spitting in it
like yelling and spitting and doing a
lot of that stuff and then the comic that
was like in the booth by the
Improv next to me, it was like,
I wish I brought my own mic
and I was like that's so funny.
It's true cause part part of the time.
You do get up there and you're like,
Oh God, this fucking record. By the
way, he realized how it wouldn't be.
It wouldn't be that crazy.
Sounds crazy,
but the reality is it wouldn't be that
crazy to show up at gigs. I'd be like, Oh,
and I brought my mic and you're
like, they'd be like, okay,
and then you plug it in. It'd be like a
forgotten thing. Totally should do it.
Bands who play, like when you go
to see like a band at the whiskey,
they all bring their own shit.
They don't share the same many things,
so they're like,
I don't want to share that guys,
Mike or or drums or they replace
everything and no one cares.
It's not like it's a good idea.
We should start doing that.
I think it would be even funnier if
we just carried like a wind sock.
We just put it over just to protect the
shows at the comedy store where the guy
before me sick sniffling and everything.
I'm like asshole.
When I first moved to La, Don Barris, who
does the, the, the, the late night led,
the last spot at the comedy store.
He probably, and maybe still does,
he would lick the mic. No. Wow. Yeah.
Would lick the microphone and like rub
it all over his body and it really start
laughing. God, you can get a whiff
of a Mike and you're like, oh,
that's what disease and death and just
a horror smell like sad. A lot of sad.
You know,
it doesn't smell these mikes fresh.
These are brand new brand we're going to
do. We're doing ASM are right now where
that is so weird that that's a huge,
I mean props if that's your thing.
But I tried watching one.
I get uncomfortable with that Cetera.
But people fucking love it. No, Nikki
Glaser came in and told her, she was like,
I'm one of those people.
It sends tingles down my back.
I can't cause cause I watched
the one, um, there's this,
she's actually kind of funny to this
black chick on youtube who she has really
long nails that she oftentimes we'll like
touch the mic with her nails and shit
and people, I mean the comments, it's
like millions of people like love it.
But I tried. That's what she
does. She does. That's her
thing. I mean she also does,
it's kind of like a podcast
too, I think. Like she does,
she talks and talks about stuff.
But yeah,
she just like analyze analyzes like a
bag of Doritos and she's slowly opens it.
She talks about you imagine that's
your fucking lane. You're like,
you see my new house, my fucking
car. I'm like, what? What do you do?
Open Dorito bags and I,
I scratched the microphone and Tom Tom's
making a lot of money doing that Dorito
thing he does. We're just talking about
it at the lunch break here that you know,
the metrics involved like networks
will have the Nielson family retreats,
which I've never met a Nielson family.
We'll navigate such a lie.
I've never met one either, but I've
heard of one. You know what I mean?
You know someone that knows someone
that has one. That's the only,
that's the closest I've come is my friend
said that his friends were a Nielson
family. I don't know who, you know what
I think might be the Nielsen families.
There it is. Yup. This is the
Birkman. Oh, you need to, Oh,
you need a separate burp and fart. Fart.
Mine. I think the Nielson family. Oh,
this is, I don't want a bourbon.
This is too nice. I'm going to be,
I'm going to be a polite
guest. Yeah, you stare at her.
You just burped in the bike. I think
the Nielson family, those people,
when you know,
when you drive and you see a house with
a huge satellite on the back of like a
huge dish, you know what I mean?
Not the direct TV, like a big one.
They have like a radio, so that's the
Nielsen Guy. That's who I think that is,
because I remember those in the 80s like
people got like there's a channels back
then was huge dishes and they're like
sitting in their yard and I always was
like,
I don't know,
that looks like it gets gotta be
government issued or something.
That's the Nielsen thing. Like I don't
know anyone that's known them direct,
but someone's like, yeah, he lives next
to my uncle. He's that guy, you know,
he like Moe's with the mower that's not
automatic, you know, the fucking level.
And when we were just talking before
we were on like you worked at old navy,
I worked at old navy and I was thinking
immediate thought was like you had
record sales. I did. I was actually
a really good salesman at old navy.
I'm not kidding. I really was.
Well this is really funny.
I joked about being the sandals salesman,
but because like sandals at old navy
or kind of like, um, $3, well not even,
I think they're like two,
two,
two like they're like two for two
for four or something like that.
They're right by the front register. So
you, so like every time I was at checkout,
I would always just be like, you
want to go some sandals? Or you know,
people like without thought would just
be like, okay, the power of suggestion.
Oh my God. Well they're there and
they're just kind. Someone always goes,
I guess I need sandals.
Or you always do for summer or if you're
going on a vacation, hopping around.
I'm thinking of like those, those weird
purchases because you do it with gum.
Like you never really looking for
gum. Just happen. If somebody says,
and there's some good gum
here, you're like, oh yeah,
the socks. When you buy shoes,
like you want some socks and you're like,
you have socks, but you're like, yeah,
yeah, but those are what goes in these
shoes. So I guess I should buy those.
I should buy those too. They should
make shoes that come with socks. And
I was
like eight years,
man, man. Never taken them off. Let
me ask you a question about old navy.
My suspicions over the years, maybe fan,
fan of the gap. I love it all. And Banana.
Interesting. Two of the three
is cool to me, but like,
but like banana for some reason
it's like bananas, like, um,
j crew's like, Ya know, lame
nephew. You're like, man,
it's like office where I don't
wear too stiff as close. Yeah.
But correct me if I'm wrong,
I feel like old navy sizing is this,
everything's a size up the gap,
but they make it appear a
size smaller for instance.
And Old Navy too is a reality for,
you know,
eight is really a 10.
Do you think it's probably because of uh,
well I think old navy is,
volume is probably way bigger.
So they serve as more people
than the gap does. Right.
So I imagine it's because of the average
human American body is a little bit
bigger, but they do do that. Right?
I've noticed that the sizes are bigger,
but they say that there are smaller and
I think it's also because like if they
ever made a mistake in the
sweatshop when they were like,
make it a four and they just made a
billion of them and they're like, okay,
that's that now. That's
what, that's our shirts now.
I think they just have to like stick
stick to it at some point. It's a mass.
Yeah. Old Navy is basically Costco
for a close. And by the way,
Costco has great clubs, ironically
enough. They sell like brick clothes.
I had a guy yesterday telling
me, he was like, dude,
he had a huge chunky watch on and I was
sitting at my local bar watching the
bears lose and I don't want to get
into it, but it's fine. I mean anyway,
and this guy had a huge yeah,
except for that.
And then it ends on a kicker missing
and kick butt, whatever. Um, he, I said,
where'd you get the water from? We
go to Costco. I was like, really?
That looks like a nice, nice. He
goes, dude, it is everything. Yeah.
He hits me in the face with it, but he
was like, yeah, no. Usually these are,
you know, whatever, 800 bucks, whatever.
And I got it for one 29. I was like,
how does Costco do that? There's gotta be
some weird science to it. They're like,
tricking us all ready?
Here we go.
Yeah,
I love it.
In the boots. They both nodded. Smile.
That's exactly what we wanted to,
I've been for,
well it's official. We're
wrapping up the studio. That's it.
That's the only reason why
I am so proud of you.
Your tears in your eyes.
What is real love? Wow.
She goes about to have
another fucking baby.
Can you smell by the way,
easily for today, my worst
fart. You know what I mean?
Yeah. I had some rips earlier, but that
was just kind of, that was the weekend.
It was one of those like you
guys soundproof. Did you smell,
smell proof the studio. I would
stay over there. How are you?
I'm gonna sit right here. Oh my God.
I was the best moment of my life.
Just do you guys fart in
bed together all day? Yeah,
but not like you got to get a whiff of it.
I mean,
you know it's interesting because I,
I know there's some couples that I've
talked to that don't fart and bet the farm
outside of bed in front of each other,
but in bed they won't.
You know what can be interesting.
Would you show our buddy cause that guy
that in bed and tell me how you think
you would handle something like this.
So can we just address the fact
that moment took 10 years to happen?
I know, I know. And it
finally just happened.
Can I tell someone I'm proud to be here
for that moment and we're proud to have
you. Thank you. I just want to, it's
really huge guys. That was major for me.
I don't know. That was a big deal.
Thanks. I do you want to make it?
I make a speech. Well you know
before I farted before on this show,
but you got to stand up. You got
to hold thing. It's a whole thing.
And to have a designated Fart,
Mike, I really, you know,
you see it like Golden Globes last night.
I really want to thank,
I'm serious here.
You're 100% do the credit because
when we were leading up to this,
I mentioned earlier,
I was concerned about the light and the
video and these mikes and making sure
the control booth was ready to go and
the Internet and you last week we were
testing video and audio and you were like,
God dammit is that Fart Mike Ready?
And when the dog was like, no,
it's not really a priority. You Go,
why are we even moving?
Why are we moving if we're not going
to step up our game and you really,
listeners,
it's important to me.
I don't know how important it
is to the listeners. Email us,
wait to hear how many
people are like please,
this has to be a highlight.
You're going to get a lot of
the birth of my children, my
wedding day. One, two, three. Yeah.
Easy. Yeah. That's great.
It's really something. I don't
know. I feel blessed though.
That's going to be at
your eulogy by the way.
Birth the children married and
the FARC. Mike. That's true.
I know.
I love you,
but I want to show Andrew this.
So this guy,
I already liked the image,
he's videoing himself.
Go ahead and give him a little
taste of what's about to happen,
baby. What is you could get into me.
Yeah.
So is this what you and your lady or
like the way that he goes, you know,
so we know that a poop who was coming
comment and we just don't know what's
going to happen. Like is she about to run
out of the room? What's going to happen?
So I'll uh,
go ahead. Sorry. Oh No. Rush to boot now.
Giddy up. Ah, well bite my head. Okay,
what else I'm running?
Do you see my fucking face? I did see
an I, that's exactly why we play these.
Oh my God. And then I
genuinely am like, oh,
this is so funny. He's going
to shit his pants. No, no,
no. And she's like, hurry up.
Oh,
Ooh.
Yes. Right in your mouth. No, no. Yeah,
no guys.
No right in their mouth.
What would you do if your
wife started this with you?
If wanted me to fart in her mouth. That's
it. Seriously. That is it. Do it again.
Yeah. Let's see the yard in your
mouth? Yeah. What's the problem?
I don't see the big
no problem.
Phone is ringing an old time we phone.
What kind of shape?
What percentage of checks you think
are are into this? Yeah, it's got it.
Who to 2% of women into this less the no,
I think two is a pretty safe number.
People under some weird shit.
Have you seen the videos on it? I mean you
will have it. Have you guys, what am I,
what am I asking?
You've seen people that love to get
kicked in the Dick as hard as it. Yes.
We talked about that.
That should be a way lower percentage and
it's way higher than I think like I've
seen the videos on line and it had like
40 million views and you're like well
people like this and like
there's the one we watched.
We watched that like Argentine one where
she was like suffered and she's like
pulling, holding his nuts down.
She was like, I want to suffer,
I want to see the blood and then she
just like, like a fucking speed bag.
Just drills him. It makes me nauseous
when I source like penis stuff.
That stuff just makes me laugh. But
like anytime tugging, punching, kicking,
pulling, penis, wolf, I can't, I don't
know how but that that's repulsive.
But good for them if they're in love.
Yeah. If that's the, if that's their love,
if that's what it is.
I just also think, um,
something is violently
wrong with that girl.
So that will be a deal breaker
for you and your wife? Yeah,
I feel like if you're going to eat farts,
I feel like that's it for us.
What if she's like so perfect and every
other way and I've heard you speak
glowingly of your wife. Yeah.
And she was like, Oh look,
all I'm asking is that
when you got to Fart,
every once in a while you tap
me on the shoulder. You let it,
you let me know and I eat it. Um, ah, no,
you don't need to do I feel like,
you know, if she says, hey babe,
I really want you to Fart in my mouth.
And I would say anything else?
Pick literally anything else, anything.
She goes, do you want me to come or not?
Not Anymore.
Not if that's your thing.
But she doesn't even look like she's
getting sexual pleasure out of that.
That's just, uh, that's just like a thing
they do. Let's talk about this though.
But what, what's the harm in it
for you? If that's what she liked?
Cause I have to kiss her mouth at some
point. So Ryan, so Ryan was saying,
well that's just the next logical step.
What am I,
am I never going to kiss her
over again? No. What if we,
what if you were pants or jeans or some
thick denim so that the fart particles
don't actually get into her
mouth? It depends on, you know,
I did some research after,
after doing you guys a show and there's
only so many genes that have enough
thick enough denim to
protect the FARC particles.
There's only two made around the world.
Maybe you had a whole whole jeans or
one of them and then this company out of
Alaska. Okay. No, but I
think, I think first of all,
that's boxers. He's in
boxers. Oh, he's got that.
He's really pushing it. He's pushing
boxers. Might as well be paper machete.
So that part's the streaming right into
her mouth or you about to go please,
please. I feel like it's
on the precipice, but we,
you know how like light make someone
sneezes. What makes someone far?
What can you do that? I want to
jump the gun here guys. Okay. Okay.
Give me a minute. I don't do
that to us man. I got real
excited. I know. I'm sorry.
You're on deck right now. We need to in
the batter's box swinging a doughnut.
I'm afraid I'm going to pee
myself cause I worked the pushing.
If you push too hard place to let God
let it happen when he wants to or she,
I don't mean to gender.
What gender do you ever,
do you ever pee when you fart? Yeah,
I, since I had my Second Child,
I pee when I cough, I
pee when I laugh. Ooh.
It just happens because
your muscles are so weak.
I just gave birth five months ago so it's
still kind of still tighten them back
up. It's still, I'm still reeling
back in. Yeah, I get that.
Do you have, do you have is leakage
of thing? That's a big deal. Yeah.
You can buy panties that
actually absorb the,
the little amounts of pea that you
create. All that. Don't do that for guys.
You guys should have that.
Do you have a little bit of leakage?
Do you have a little bit
dribble? Yeah. Isn't that crazy?
And no one talks about that, like that's
why don't you have a pad in the front?
Oh, like underwear built with a
little bit of pad for absorption.
We've got two ideas on the show,
but I feel like we could sell,
make billions of dollars. I don't
know what the fuck we're doing. Yeah,
I feel like that's the thing that
nobody wants to talk about that men,
as you get older, every guy has a
little bit of drip edge, but no one,
no one says anything. So you go
pee and then the lows a little bit.
There's always a little bit,
even if you shake, you know,
especially after we've
been having a few drinks.
Then if I shake in a Pete whatever,
I still got some.
And sometimes you walk away from like
a urinal and you're like, oh my God,
I think I'm pissing down my thing.
I'm still just pissing, yeah,
it's not dribbling. I'm
full, full pissing my pants.
Now when I bring this up because
I imagine you have pretty
good game. Okay. It's just
like a sense that I have and
we have a, we played a guy,
uh, we, we're not going to play in
right now, but this guy became a, uh,
quite a hit on the show for his very
forward approach to contacting this woman,
Julia. That's right. Okay.
And then I'm excited we got,
so we got ahold of this is
just voicemails, voicemails,
apparently,
I don't know how long they've been around.
They've been around a few years at least,
but we've never heard them.
So this woman release these voice mails
that this man left on her phone and
we'll play them in succession. Like how,
how she received that. Okay. This is true.
This is Julia. No, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no. Totally different persons.
Different woman releasing voicemails
that a different guy, but you can,
you can hear the build. Okay. Yeah. Things
changed. Yeah, it was such a good fart.
Hi Ashley.
This is Davey is five o'
clock Tuesday afternoon.
I don't know what time you coming home.
If you have time,
maybe we can go right hitting Brandwidth.
You can have dinner together right here
in Brooklyn. You call me back please.
Three mono line or one bye bye.
Okay. I know you edited that,
but a piece of me is like, God,
this guy doesn't even know how to
say his phone number three one oh,
he reminds me a lot. I remember.
Reminds you of um, yes. Yes.
This is David. I'm, I'm guessing
David's not as God given
Salah May. By the way. Solomon is a,
they're a lady was late leaving extensive
messages on Christina's mom when she
switched her number.
How did she get your number? No, when I
switched my phone number to a new, Oh,
it was something I've done. I've had that
before. Yeah, right. For a years I'll get,
I still get like dry. This guy's a drug
dealer. Hits me up if I want Xanax.
And then this other one that's
kind of Nice to be on drugs,
it's like a gambling
thing. He's like, hey,
the Knicks versus the whatever
you want in. I'm like, Geez,
you adopt a burner phone
number you've got to generate.
Never. That called me. She
would get mad and calling me.
She would leave most of the message in
Farsi and then we'd have people translate
and they were like, Yo,
she's raw dude. She's like,
tell this mother fucker to get the,
she was telling her how to keep
wearing pearls out of her fruits,
like Thai plastic bags all
around your training like crazy.
So this guy keep going with this guy.
Hi,
I see you said Davey is
7:30 PM Tuesday night.
Oh, it's the same night call on my phone.
I don't know if you were trying
to call me back. No, I didn't.
I missed you or what happened or
just avoiding my phone didn't ring,
but I have your number as a miss.
If you did call me,
can you please call me back again?
Nice.
7:30 PM three one zero nine
eight imagine leave this
guy two hours later.
Hey maybe you called and wires
got crossed to the operator,
not put you through to the right.
What year is this guy?
I think this is my
favorite move is like a,
I see the missed call and I think that
maybe it's you even though I don't see
that you call, here's my number
again just in case. Yeah. Jessica,
just in case you saw me already
bothered you before. Did I wonder if,
did he send texts as well?
I don't know if he sent texts.
Definitely left more messages.
Let's see.
Can you just call me for five minutes
or I should
just forget about you.
I told you a decent human being but it
seems to me is you are not so I don't
know what to tell you.
I taught you or someone I can talk.
Then you are somebody decent so can you
just call me for five minutes if you are
not available so I can just throw
you a number to the garbage.
It was very odd to just print out a phone
number and then throw it in the trash.
You picked up on the fact that
as that message was ending,
there was some anger building
10 throw to the garbage.
That's how I pizza.
You were a decent human being by the way.
He mentioned that twice.
I thought you were a decent human being,
not someone who would call every two
hours bugging you. That's a good person.
We're on. Call me. Yeah, number
three. So it's five seven 39 yeah,
on a Tuesday. About
Friday. Can't be that busy.
You can't be that busy and a decent
person wouldn't be that busy. Impossible.
Decent human beings aren't busy.
So do you,
are you going to call me back or should
I throw your shit in the trash right now?
You can feel just the end. He goes,
so I don't know what to tell you.
It's like almost a murderer's ploy.
And his brain was deciding whether
to say something aggressive or not,
and then he ended with like wood
or do I throw in the garbage?
Like he didn't know whether it'd be
like, fuck you right back. But he,
but he saved himself at the end
by just saying, just come on.
Call me back or month or do
I just need to stop this?
I wonder if you call us again.
Maybe. Maybe this one's nicer.
I don't know what the fuck
is wrong with your phone.
Oh, nice. That's great.
I don't know what the fuck
is wrong with your phone.
Every time you con you disconnected,
I don't know what the fuck is wrong
with this phone call or the way is,
I cannot even talk to you.
What is this?
What does he know how that works? Wait, so
disconnected. First of all,
he didn't leave a time,
didn't leave his phone number again.
I feel like the consistency is broken
now and so now we know he's mad.
Every time he calls his disconnected.
What does that mean?
The phone is disconnected? Yeah. We
don't know what's going on. It's broken.
You know how often your cell phones
gets it's gonna disconnect it.
That's such a common name.
What the fuck you call it again?
I see another missed call,
Ashley. Yeah, so, so this is is,
is this the beginning of the me
too movement is this kind of list?
This is how I start. It
should be, but there's no way.
Okay. Ah, fuck a prostitute.
So many fucking
fuck you are.
You're 14
and dismissal for motherfuckers to four,
three, four, three or four prostitutes.
I would love to have a counter on
that. That it, that sounds like,
you know when somebody takes Spanish
101 when like a white kid and he only
learns a few cuss words. Yeah. And
he says them over and over and over.
Like he did that
fucking phone.
Mother fuckers.
Motherfucker prostitute. Yeah. Yeah.
Mother fucker prostitute. Yeah. Um,
I mean this is good. Uh, let's go
to numb. Yeah, that one, right?
Pardon me?
I knew there's so many bad,
so many
still.
Do
you think I need it?
I said you are beautiful.
You are cops fucking mother fucker
because
you,
I
have to put it
short.
Call me anyway.
Cocksucker motherfucker.
I got to say this could be a
nice monologue piece for you.
I like it as a performance
because I printed out the
pause because I have to put
the pillow over your face.
It just such a fuck.
I mean it really emphasized.
Yeah. You know, it is, it
is very obvious when Rachel,
yeah, that was a little mean.
You can just stick to prostitute,
cock sucker motherfucker.
And then you've been good and necessary.
Yeah, no, it's interesting.
Is that what good morning Julia and this
guy have in common with doctor drew was
mentioning was that narcissism?
Yes.
It's the same thing of like he was
waiting for Joe to turn ugly like that and
said this guy ended up
turning. Yeah. Yeah.
So it drew analyze the good morning Julia
Guy. He was just bracing. He's like,
he's like, so it's, it's about to get
violent or grotesquely sexual, you know,
and yeah, it didn't go there. And then
he was just like, wow, this is, you know,
this guy's obviously has like
kind of sense of a grandiose,
you know, feel really illusions
of grand jury. Yes, yes. And,
and basically most people like that and
like this or without shame too. You know,
you can't shame them. But this guy,
he does it. He does anything here.
That's very interesting.
Let's if we psychoanalyze this for people
that have no background doing this at
all or schooling,
I'll just say,
he says you're a cock sucker motherfucker.
And then he says,
you can suck my cock motherfucker.
And then he says, and then he said,
you're too ugly to suck my cock. Right.
He wants it,
but he doesn't want it.
He's playing real hard to get here
and then go suck some black dicks.
Maybe he's in the cooking.
Maybe he wants to see her suck on the
black cause that's what that seems like.
Yeah. So you cock sucker. Go Suck Black
Hawks. You can't suck mine. You should.
You should suck. You're
too ugly to suck. Mine.
I'll cover your head but let you stuck up.
Okay.
This guy is full circle. He's
all over the map. He's emotional.
He's emotionally unavailable is I think
what this is. Yeah, that's the breakdown.
I think he wished he could be really
more attuned with what's going on,
his emotions and he just Kinda, it's a
cry for help. It's a cry for help. Yeah.
I think, I think, I think his last
relationship ended very poorly.
I think that's what really happened
here. He's trying, could you imagine?
But this is essentially the guy in
the bar who's like in Brentwood,
what's a bright white, but he's like,
Hey, what's up? What's your name?
And he's drunk. And then you're like, I'm
not interested. Fuck you, bitch. Yeah.
It's that. That's a real guy. You
experienced that of your whole life?
My whole life. But he's
usually very drunk. Yeah.
You can see them coming a mile
away. You know it. You know what?
The minute he talks to you,
he's fuck it.
You've had enough guys in your dating
life experiences that have done it.
Okay,
that have done that to you, that
have been like, yeah, you're hot,
and then you're like, I'm good. And
they're like, fuck you. Yes a lot.
It had a cool tactic. That's, I mean,
it's got to work all the time. It happens.
You did it. Every one of those guys
[inaudible] everyone, I'm married,
I'm married one every like every time
you're out late night at a bar by 2:00 AM
that guy rolls, right? So alcohol
plays a part. I am always,
but see that's why la closes at two and
that happens, uh, places like Chicago,
they never close.
So you kind of just avoid that to
some degree cause those guys just keep
blacking out on high closing
time. That makes, um,
it's that sense of I got to
get it down pat. Yes. Yeah.
Chicago bars or four or 5:00 AM
they just end up sleeping there.
They go ask a girl and a girl
was like, I'm good. And like,
and they just keep drinking and then
they just live there for a day or two.
That's crazy. I've seen that by the way.
I've seen guys sleep at the bar sleep,
put them outside, put them in
an alley or on a, you know,
then wake up and they're like, hey,
I got something to drink. Yeah,
you want something to drink? It's seven.
We started serving an hour ago. God,
it's a good life.
Hey if that's all you got
do, that was our deal because that
seems pretty, they just had a, um,
they just had a vote this past
session to put it to three,
maybe to 3:00 AM and how'd that go?
They shut it.
They shut it down at lost by
like a landslide. What? Yeah,
because it was something about, um, the,
there's a budget increase then in
police force, uh, to deal with,
to deal with assholes that are
leaving the bar. Black problems. Yeah.
There's all sorts of bullshit.
Such a like a bump of people
spending money out that it
would be worth it though.
I don't, maybe not
though. So you say that,
but I think like a lot of times people
get so fucked up so early. They,
I think a lot, most people leave
the bar before 2:00 AM yeah.
Because they know it's going to close.
Do you know what I mean?
Like either go get more liquor
and go to someone's house.
I feel like it at 2:00 AM only on peak.
Maybe a Saturday night is the bar packed
when it closes every other night of the
week. It's like, you know,
staggered. I feel like that's,
I feel like every time I go out and I
see that if I've ever closed the bar,
I look around, I'm like,
we're, we're pretty sad.
There's like 15 of us sad people here
staring at each other. The lights go on,
you know, like we should go home.
Everyone's like, yeah, this is a bummer.
This is like a really pathetic
underwear. England, it closes at 11 yeah.
Well the British people drink all
day, all day. So you started earlier.
They don't really have, I don't
think they care because they're like,
they wake up and like, oh, grab a pint
and eggs and beans. You can't last.
If you really do that, you know, like
your days where you're like, it's,
it's morning.
You're like,
let's get drink and right now
people do it and I'm so impressed.
I'm going to be honest, if I say like, oh,
we're going to a baseball game and
I'm going to have a couple of beers,
the night is called off, whatever I
was going to happen that night. Can't,
can't exist. It's over. Yeah. Won't exist.
I'll be at home and people like you have
to come out and you remember when you
fuck that guy, Rick in Charlotte,
he told me, we tell this story 100%.
So I met Rick in Charlotte.
Uh, well I should say this.
I met him in the Appalachian Mountains,
right.
So I met him in the mountains and
we were both hiking. Yes. And, uh,
what happened was,
is I'm hiking during the day and
I was a little bit sad and lonely.
I was gonna have a big fight with my
significant other. And uh, this guy, Rick,
I was out of water.
My camel pack had ran out of water
and the ric had had a Campbell,
pat had a one of the 12 gallon at first.
It's just like necessity. I, well, I,
I was kind of bending over co dry
coughing, you know, and he goes, hey bud,
you know, he's on another P, you
thirsty? I said, I love it. And he goes,
you can suck on my pole. So that's
what they call them, suck on my poles,
sharing camel backs. So he
walks over to the, you know,
the other peak with me and you know, I'd
give him, first of all, I give him a big,
big hug. Yeah. Big Guy.
Real big guy. Yeah.
Kind of like I'm a real heavy,
probably like three 30,
three 45. Wow. But not tall. You know,
he was a short for 10 for
10 but three 53 65 maybe.
And he shoved his full in my mouth. Yeah.
Big Guy. Shoved it right in my mouth is,
you know, and just, you know, made me
suck and I sucked it down. And um, I said,
you know, I have a show tonight. I'd
love you to come see me to stand up.
And he said, no chance, but you
can meet me at my hotel afterwards.
And he's not a comedy fan. That's
crazy. Yeah, it was nuts. It was nuts.
You still went and did your show bombed?
Bombed two sets.
Because I just was thinking about Rick
the whole time and the moment I got off
the second set, you know, the owner was
like, oh fuck, I was all mad, you know,
as I was like I gotta Roll Dude.
And I went right to that Hyatt
and just how fun was that?
It was at first it was a little
daunting to be honest with you,
cause he is a large man and I just did,
you know,
there was never a discussion over
top or bottom. It was pretty obvious.
So you know, um, I was
recovery. Uh, not bad.
I mean not too bad.
At least he made me an ice bath,
which it's takes so many trips to go to
the hallway because of the ice machines.
Never ever, ever just a
little baby bucket. Yeah.
So we borrowed a few buckets from
other people. We kind of got,
it was like a communal community thing.
It was like pass the bucket down and
everyone was like, why are we doing this?
If someone's sick, if someone
hurt. And you know, I bent over,
I opened up my moon pie and I
showed him what happened. And uh,
I sat in there for about an hour
and a half and everything was fine.
I got to say, it's one of
my favorite stories. Yeah.
But can I update you on something
because you've asked me a few times.
Rick has fled the country. Where
is he? You know, he said he, he,
I got a suspicious email.
Um,
I have some weird suspicion email and it
just said I'm leaving and I'm going to
the Netherlands.
So I think this fall is going to be my
trip to the Netherlands to try to find
Rick. Wow, cool. You could probably build
a tour around it, write it off, you know,
I love that. I would absolutely
love that. But then again,
I'll be thinking about Rick not comedy the
whole time. Yeah. Your Bom, Bom, Bom, bom.
And that's pretty cool. Yeah, it's so
romantic. It kind of is. It kind of is.
You know, and in this modern
age, no one really talks about,
nobody really will romanticize every time
two guys have like a gay joke and film,
they're always like, oh, you know,
it's, it's just, it's too cheap.
This was real love. This was real cool.
Yeah. For the first time in a long time.
I gotta tell Ya. I remember
when I met, uh, Saint Tino,
I was like, Hey Tom. He goes,
I'm just glad you're not named Rick. Oh,
that's a weird thing to say. Sure. Yeah.
But why? And then he told me the whole
story. Do you say it to everybody?
And he's like, if they're not named
Rick, I do. Most men. Yeah. Yeah.
Well I don't trust most guys after
experiences like that. Oh my bad. Yeah.
So I just, you know, that, that, that,
and that stuck with me and I know you
brought it up cause it's the podcast,
but it does stings a little
bit. I'm sorry. That's okay.
This is your show and a, that's
true. I'm going to let it go.
I didn't mean to hijack, no,
come on. No, no, no. It's not
disrespectful. Not at all.
No. It's respectful. It's respectful
because it's your, it's your house,
your mom's house. I want to make
something clear. We are overjoyed.
First of all that you're going to
the Netherlands to find Rick. Yeah.
But secondly that whiskey,
ginger,
your podcasts that everyone should
subscribe to, please download, review,
thumbs up, stars, write a love letter. Uh,
also you will very soon be able to
watch the watch his podcast here on this
youtube channel. He's going to
record it in this set over here. Yup.
And the video coming up. We'll be coming
up on Monday, starting in like two weeks.
Is that right? Or something like
that. Give or take. All right, so,
but it will be a regular thing where
you can watch the video on the youtube
channel or you can download and listen to
whiskey. Ginger, you are hilarious dude.
So I, I'm super, super pumped that you're
doing. Thank you. I'm so, I'm excited to,
you know, like, uh, I know
this sounds like I'm pandering,
but you guys are kind of,
I mean there's only two or three people
that really told me to kind of get into
it and you guys are kind of part
of the reason that I did it.
I avoided doing a podcast for a long
time cause I just was like, I don't know.
I don't know. And I like doing other
people's podcasts, but I just didn't,
I just didn't feel like I was like,
ah,
I don't have anything to
offer and all that shit.
But you guys were kind of the part of the,
the last thing that pushed me over the
edge to do it honestly for Rick and do it
for Rick, but I have this weird fewer
natural man. You natural. Thanks man.
I have this weird fear.
He's not listening. That's
the weird thing, you know?
And that kind of eats me alive.
There could be like a cool Easter
egg in every episode for Rick.
You know what I mean?
Shout out to Rick,
like maybe you get a camelback and
you kind of do things. That's my,
that's my Carol Burnett sign off.
I stuck a little bit of a cold.
I can't hold back for Rick
exactly. Or like, you know,
I don't remember what you said.
Was it a favorite food?
But maybe we put a little bit, you don't
remember? I said what? I said I forget.
Are you serious? Wait. It was, was
it pistachios or I as a chicken pie.
Pistachio Mash.
That's like some elaborate.
I've told I've told you this 10 10 12
times Robert to have set up, you know,
to get, I was looking at putting
a little bowl of it on the,
you have a studio here. We got. These
guys can cook some shit up. All right.
I'm sending a recipe and I want that every
time. All right. That's in my writer.
It's a chicken pie or pistachio
mash. Wow. Have you never had that?
It's a delicious dish. Well, Rick turned
me onto it. Oh my God. Can we move on?
This is going to really,
that's, that's crazy. Bury me.
I don't want to get you going,
but I also have this clip.
Sorry ma'am.
Rains and the corner.
That really goes deep for me.
I have a clip of Pristina haven't
played yet on the show. Ready?
There you go.
You sound great there by the way.
My older,
my career before.
How did you skip out on
having the valley voice and
super conscious of it?
When I get with my BFF Shauna who
grew up in the valley too, we,
we are regressing to like, oh my God
dude. Like fucking Bro. Like dude bro.
Like Bro, but that,
but, but, but Sally up,
speak up, speak up. Speak that kid.
That was a revival with Paris
Hilton I think in those girls.
But she did that Paris Hilton was
kind of like the Nicole Nicole.
That girl brought it back,
I don't know,
but there was big in the
eighties speaking to come back.
You know Lindsay Lohan is got a TV
show now you guys know does MTV,
I just saw a billboard on
sunset and they immediately it,
that's the name of the show that
I googled it.
She has a fucking show on TV about rehab
or something. Yeah, I imagine it's life.
It's her life. It's just, it's a reality
show. It's got to be sad though. She,
she was so talented. I know.
Isn't it weird that that
talented goes the other way?
Yeah. I like, it's w I never,
that's so strange to me. So fuck,
when you're kind of mediocre
town mediocre and you fall off,
like if what I ended up falling off,
people will go, yeah, okay, that's fine.
But when you like, when you're like
huge and you're the thing for sure.
Now look at them. I'm giving
you, put Rick in my head.
Rick used to tell me you're not worth it.
That was kind of my favorite.
That was turned me on.
You're not worth desk.
And he had this sweet deep voice.
We have to get a search party.
We got to find Rick in the Netherlands
and you toward another one 65 well we all
get, let's can we go? So we
get, maybe he's gonna stand out.
Those people were all long and
lean. You know, you'll find your,
Hannah mentioned it. People are like, Oh,
you're talking about like short fat Rick.
Yeah, I know exactly know gay
Rick. That's the name of it.
That's the name of the tour
back yet. Let's find Rick.
Let's fine. Rick, the tour.
I'll go. I'm, I'm, I'm, I'm so down.
I'm very sorry. Lindsay. Load hands. No,
nothing. She, I feel she's
doing a TV show and I can't,
it's just so funny to think that there's
so much good garbage television man.
It's awesome. I think it, do you
watch the bachelor bullshit or no? No,
we're really in the bachelor of
the bachelor. It just started.
We're watching 90 day fiance.
I'm all over it.
It's one of my favorite shows I've
ever seen, ever created. Ever credit.
You know what Brexit might
have after lockup. I like it.
But 90 Day has more drama you like, yeah.
90 Day has better drama for me. The kid,
the kid, um, and the names
are bad. I'm bad with names,
but the kid who has the wife that has
the baby over over in Russia that he had
to come back.
I believe their love.
I actually believe that actually believe
their love. You also empathize with him.
When you see them getting angry,
you're like, you're young.
You just got to work to shut out.
Totally take a couple deep breaths.
Just kids like going through a
weird love struggle and I buy that.
You know what I mean?
Well,
so much responsibility at such a
young who's loved by the most, uh,
well there is no, there is
literally no love between the, uh,
the girl who has two kids
from two different dads.
The blonde girl with the Jamaican guy.
See, she does have two kids. Yeah,
she's mentioned that.
She's mentioned it. Okay.
Another reason that I don't believe it's
real love because this woman has two
children. You never even see
that this is what she mentioned,
that I go like three episodes
and you're like, shit,
it's never come up again probably with
their father so she can do this nonsense
show. I gotcha. I see. That's why I
don't believe in any of that. Also,
like I think he cheated
on the wedding day,
which is a bowl that is a bold move.
I mean, if you're going that far yet,
we haven't made it to the wedding day.
Sorry,
I'm the, I'm the Queen Bitch. That girl
who's like on the stairs, she's like,
that is, I like you. You biggie.
How sick and the Cottica we get to Biggie
Pooley she's so great and she hates
the mother.
A biggie.
Poorly gets a biggie booty
and her teeth are enormous.
People know, wow, look big money.
Her teeth are bigger than veneers, you
know, bigger than those. She's like, yeah,
like the big, the Steve Harvey's, she,
she's good. And the um, the kid, the,
that, that's the vague,
that's Vegas, Vegas, Vegas.
That's my favorite part
that goes with this mom.
And she hates the place that they live
and he lives with his mom. That poor guy.
I don't even, I, oh, I feel so bad
for him. It's not even fun anymore.
Do you know there's like some
people on the show, you're like,
I don't feel about you trapped yourself.
Like the dad that disowned his daughters.
Yeah. So the other girls, it's like, dude,
I don't feel bad for you, but the Vegas
Guy, I feel sad for him because he like,
he loves Vegas, he loves his mom.
This girl is like, Fuck Vegas,
you mom is bitch and shit. And he's like,
I love you. You're my dream girl. He, uh,
it's the, it's like, we always say
like cool. At one point he's like,
well, you're, everyone knows
a boy's best friends. His mom,
and then they have like a, a joint bank
account. He and his mother, 33, 33.
She's like,
what about when we get married?
What are you going to do as far
as the bank account? He's like,
just keep you on it. You
know, all three of us,
all three of us would be
like a big happy family. Mom.
My wife and I share a checking account,
checking account.
It's, so, imagine the fights
that will come from that,
that the mother is like fighting
with a Brazilian over what she saw.
She bought on their check.
I mean like couples do that.
Husbands and wives do that.
Wow. That was way better than
yours. Wow. Yeah, that was, dude.
Are you pushing off the leather?
Are you getting lift?
That's the best day of your life.
Well, she did say kid's wedding farts,
but now it's too far, so I feel like
that it moves up. Moves up a little bit.
It was fun. That's really good. Hey,
can I tell you something here? Go ahead.
You have great compression in your farts.
Let's talk about it.
It just sounds like a perfect bubble came
out like a perfect fart bubble. Just,
yeah.
Tom's was more like,
cause there's little Ripley.
Yeah, there's also in there. Yeah.
I'm so mad because I had
such killer farts today.
I know. And then you let them all go.
They, none of them got captured. You know?
It's like when you're trying
to get a set and you're like,
a fucking killed it last night. Why
don't you set up the camera? Nothing.
Hey, can we say this? Yeah. Your
farts are just as valid as her farm.
Don't get down. You're far shaming.
You're forced shaming yourself. Yeah, no,
I know. I should just celebrate yours.
You know, try and be happy for me. Yeah,
that's true. Sorry, I'm sorry.
That was a really cool fart.
Next episode you're going to have some
parts of your own. Yeah, I have a feeling
that he heard that without
headphones in there.
That was up.
You know what I'm really happy about
is the people listening to this podcast
wearing their ear buds.
Now they can hear the FARC clear.
Imagine someone with a good sound
system in their car. The base on that.
Talk about new advertisers.
Just opening the gates for marketing.
Hello money.
How many other podcast? You know
who does have it? Your mom's house.
That's fucking right. That's the
only one. You're the only one I know.
Let me build, I also didn't eat like a big
enough thick breakfast. I'm really mad.
I was on the run this morning,
but if I had a big breakfast,
this is about the time
that I'm letting them ride.
Like I had to go pee in there before the
show run. You went for a run? Yeah, but,
but like I had to pee before the show
but like I thought another hour and I'll
have to shit and I was kind of bummed
I couldn't shit here cause I would have
loved it. Chris in this place
with my shit day one. Oh yeah,
no I mean from my front,
a personal level,
I do like to make myself known and then
place that I'm new to. Yeah, sure. Yeah.
Like every time I go to a meeting in
Hollywood I always, shit, I'm not,
I'm not joking.
I have a Cappuccino machine in my house
and I make probably three or four shots
of espresso.
Do you time it out so that you know,
if the meeting's at 11 o'clock I'm up,
I'm up at like eight o'clock to
like do work, whatever. And I,
and I have my last sip about
an hour and a half prior to,
that'll give you perfect 90 miles because
I can show up 10 minutes before the
meeting. I can go into the lobby
awkwardly talked to them one,
where is the bathroom? It's right
here. It's in the office. Perfect.
Do you let people know in the meeting
what happened or you like, Hey,
just so you guys know. Sometimes
I say to the receptionist, I go,
I've got a lot of stomach issues just so
that might get passed down the line on
one of those [inaudible] boards
shitting here and he let me know. Yeah.
He had just had an hour move and
they were like, that's definitely,
I think it's a power move. I bring my
own baby wipes wherever I go. Yeah,
just in case. Yeah, I do. They're
on your car during my car,
just in case I need to clean
up, you know, and I used to do,
I used to have comedy deodorant in my
glove box, but that's really smart.
Before nice be so nervous
and I would just put,
just to put on an extra layer
before standup, do you do, do you,
does your sweat smell?
Do you have a smelly sweat?
Because I sweat a lot sometimes,
but it won't smell it. No,
she doesn't smell well
then it doesn't matter.
Then you get the rings
on your shirt on stage.
I'd be so nervous that I
would get the sweat rate.
Third idea we're gonna make
our third product is shirts
like trauma, sweat rings.
Oh, that's so cool. They're already there.
Built in socks, sweat, ring. That's it.
And then didn't we have
something? Oh, the fart or, well,
the big catcher in the front, which by the
way will be our highest seller. I mean,
so we just chopping up are like a billion.
We just have like forklifts carrying
the money around that we're making from
these ideas. How can these guys, can
you guys help carrying money in there?
I feel like they can, they'll
figure it out. So we always,
we have like a gift for just being
sent the coolest guys on the Internet.
And I know that, uh, these videos of, of
just like guys that are out there,
they usually,
there's a certain criteria and
usually the way it looks. And anyways,
here's a new one. Oh, nice. Yes.
There's already a great image. Uh,
um, let's see. I already asked to say
very, here's my question. Why is it so
hard to meet a girl? Just to fucking fuck,
bro. Why is every girl when the come
into your life and make your life fucking
complicated.
You know what I mean? Preach. Yeah, true.
Every single piece of that was true.
Yeah. What the fuck, Bro? Why can't we
find a girl to fuck? It's like a cro.
Magnon he does. What does that, what it
does? What does that Spanish, a beautiful,
beautiful caveman. Yes.
Is this a Geico ad?
Really looks like it's stupid.
What else?
Meanwhile, their life and their situation
is solely fucking upside down. Okay.
But they want to fucking come disrupt
your life. I don't understand this shit.
Okay. A lot of women out there fully
fucking full of shit and they're stupid.
Straight up.
Here's what's weird.
He says their life was upside down.
I feel like perhaps his
might be upside down. Well,
what's in the back will tell
you this before we play this,
this fits all the mold for a perfect,
your mom's house video.
Go ahead, Tom. What are the criteria?
Well, uh, horrific camera angle. Got It.
Uh, less than ideal lighting. Perfect.
Um, the shortlist shirtless
Deborah was, is huge. Yeah.
Um, either missing teeth and
or unkempt in a general sense,
just got knocked that one
out of the fucking park and
some type of either a drug
induced or mental delusions that lead to
a rant that is aggressive in nature and
or disturbing. And also
don't forget, yeah,
location. Location is the right place.
Yeah. Where is he and I, and I affect shop
mommy behind him wrapped in an American
is imagine this guy picks you up for a
day. So come check out this.
You stupid fucking bitch.
Fuck you dumb bitch. Dinner was
good. You won't come and Swat you.
Stupid Bitch Bitch.
One thing to fuck with my head,
but ain't nobody gonna fuck my brother
said I'm not letting that shit go down,
so it's just gonna fucking go kick rocks.
I don't know.
I don't understand why so hard to meet
a girl just to fucking fuck I said it.
You don't like it? Delete.
Ban You. I don't give a fuck.
Whoa dude. Why is his brother had
nothing to do with this? I don't know.
It'd be nice.
It would be nice if we saw his brother's
side of it was his brother was like,
dude,
I don't support any of that shit.
It looks like a skeleton in
the background. Like it's,
it's fun. It looks normal.
What's, what do you have
in your room? I mean Shit.
All right,
but this relationship shit with bitches.
Go clean up your own backyard before you
come. So when Niggas backyard for sure.
Timeout. What? Why are they outside? Get
inside if you're going to be on a date,
he put them in near all that
cool stuff he got in the room.
Don't be in the back yard.
Cool stuff. Cool. What do we,
what is this man's name by the way?
Ted, this is Ted. I think so. It's done,
isn't it? I imagine a Ted, I was
going for something like he dropped,
he dropped big words. He did,
right? He did. He dropped it.
He dropped quite big words. Yeah.
God. The angle and here's the thing,
he's already not a traditionally
handsome man. Timeout.
What makes you say what the
fuck the fuck makes you proud?
Are you taking shots at this guys?
Looks,
what is it about this guy that's
not right? You're right. No,
I should be in the sky. It looks fucking
awesome. What are you talking about?
Two things. Sorry. Give me two things.
If you find that attractive
about him just to see,
what do you say no is it doesn't count.
Go.
Go once on the track of about
this guy. Yeah. With your size.
What's not appealing from
this angle? Right. Go ahead.
I was like, is this Brad Pitt on
a bad day? Maybe the angles. Uh,
here's the deal man. Like if you
are ready on that side, you know,
why don't you try to make the angle
flattering? It's like you just know,
like not under here is never
good. It's never going to
be good from here. Never. I,
I feel like this might be
his most dominant. What if
he's extreme? What if he's,
what if he's an LP and he, this is his
best angle is up. No thanks if he's an LP.
I never thought of that. Yeah. Look
at the door behind him. See the,
like the bride of Chucky doll. It's so
beautiful. Yeah. Gorgeous art. Yeah.
That's just so great. Gorgeous
art. Can you zoom in on that?
That doll that is Harry Truman on
that dog in the background? No,
fuck it.
Well, it's up on my Instagram. Hey guys,
I'm on a roll today because
women are fucking stupid. Okay.
They're fucking stupid.
Why?
It's so difficult for good guys
to me to fucking saying woman.
I don't understand why everyone
was a fucking stupid idiot.
Could there be like some could there
maybe be like some paralysis or something
going on? Like just the way that,
so maybe we should feel bad for him.
The chest feel bad. You know what? If
he's w okay, you're going to feel bad.
What if he's legless? He's not like, how
do you know we don't see any of his legs?
He would make it an issue.
That might be where this anger is stemming
from. This is old legless legless Ted.
I feel bad for old leg lists and here
you are throwing shots at his looks.
Hey guys,
what am I looking at on the lower left
frame there is that, is that a tattoo?
I want to know what those tattoos are
so bad. Yeah. Oh right. I want to know,
it looks like a bird wing was probably
right off. You don't see Christina,
you big meaning it's the straw that he
blows into. Make the chair move. You know
he is fucking stupid bitch.
I mean it moves another couple of years.
Not, don't, don't you put that on me.
Do you?
You really
funny.
Are you going to be this mean to this man?
Don't shoot you guys,
don't you
the song. I just don't understand
it. I just don't do you understand?
We are in the situation we are
in because woman ate the apple.
It is woman's fucking fall.
Gimme back my fucking rib and go
back to her. Fuck you came from
dude, this is religiously informed as
well. Dude knows what's up for sure.
You telling me if this guy sent
this video out and you saw it,
you wouldn't think to give him a shot.
I let them tell you what, come on.
Oh, he does make some good points.
Where's your first date with him? Uh,
let's think about it. Hold on,
let me, let's be real. Let's be,
where's your first day? First of all,
he is he going to call? No texts.
Like they'll call, he'll call you from
a payphone? Yeah. Yeah. He'll call.
You find the one pay phone at the airport.
It's we,
it's gotta be a weird location.
And then my brother's house,
his brother and I'm going to eat,
I got to take the bus down to see
my car's in the shop in the shop.
It's such a great lie. His car's
been in the shop. There's whole life.
It doesn't have a car. Never had a car.
So he, so he takes the bus and he says,
how about we meet at the restaurant?
Do you think it's a restaurant or do
you think he's going to go Starbucks?
I think it's what he calls. He calls
everything a restaurant. How? How quick,
how quickly do you think he goes
from like, all right, we're like,
so three o'clock. So like you're
fucking stupid. Do you think,
do you think it's a matter of, if
you're like, that's three and he's like,
fucking bitch. You're like, no. I
was saying like three 15. All right.
On the edge of Andrea.
What's his life like?
This ted,
once you're really good at Teddy,
teddy, you analyze this
last time, teddy. Well,
here's the thing about teddy and the
thing that I said that I knew that you
didn't know what he is like less
and that is, that is the truth.
When Tom said about the
chair. That's true. Okay,
so he does take the bus and that's only
because the buses are equipped with
already uh,
chair loading accessibility.
How big of a side you should feel bad
about that bus driver let when he sees the
chair at the stop, Mike, the bus
driver, Mike. Mike is Mike like,
all right,
let's go to take second.
Like you think it's really
annoying to him every time.
But I can tell you this guy's chalk
full of good jokes and he always tells a
good joke when he gets it. I tend to
pretty good at your small quick stuff,
you know what I mean? Like, uh, you
know, he says, you know, like when he's,
when he was rolling on the bus the first
time Mike was annoyed and he's like,
come on dude, you know, like speed it up.
And he was like, you know, he goes, look,
you've got a leg up on me. You
know what I mean? You know,
is fakies and Mike side I could
sense. All right. So now he's like,
hey teddy. Right. The second cub,
second of times he did hold up the bus
an insignificant amount of time. Yeah.
Yeah. Cause there was a girl, the bust up,
he was calling us stupid bitch
and it was yelling at him.
These rants are common for,
for Ted. Very, very common.
But it all stems from the fact that
his brother has a bigger cock. Oh yeah.
That is a big issue in their family.
Yeah.
It's just a fact about their family.
They live together.
He and his brothers still,
or does he live alone?
Does this guy have his own apartment?
Is it going to take me back
to his own place? 10 his
brother lived together. Yeah.
Yeah. They lived in the halls and
the skeletons and all the cool stuff.
They share a room in a house in Tarzana,
so it's somebody else's home.
We don't really know those
people to be honest with you,
but they lived together
in this room for short.
Head goes like you like a doll's
and artifacts and stuff like that.
And if you're like no, see that. She's
like, you fucking idiot bitch. Yeah.
And you're like, I'm sorry.
Like here, like here,
like I'll be the girl
and on the date with Ted,
you guys go ahead and give it to me.
Give it to me. This is how I'm the girl.
Christina, are you
familiar with not really.
What does have an extensive collection?
Oh fuck you bitch. Is that what you're
saying? Is that how that was pretty good.
That was really good. Really good. Do
you see my reaction? I went like this,
but you know what? I really
went like my pussy is wet. Yeah.
The moment you yelled at me like that, I
got to see it. By the way, that red is,
I'm terrified. Where can I
go with you? Yeah. You know,
it goes back and then write in. That's
what you were like scared. I'd be like,
fuck yeah, that's what, that's
Kinda his ransom. Why he does it.
Because he said that happens so many
times, like multiple, seriously.
Where does he take, where does this guy
go on a first date? Like let's be, well,
I feel like if he could, so if you do,
you know, you're, you get the call,
you take an Uber, he takes the bus,
uh, and, and he says, let's meet up.
He says, let's meet up at this. Let's
meet up at a tire rack. You know, like a,
the to change, you know,
he's got to meet there.
That's where his brother worked
at the tire, the tire rack.
That's a tire chain store. You
don't want to tires. And He,
his brother works there.
He shows you some of the dopest tires
that they've got that smile that month on
sale. And if you're kind of not into that
because you're not into that, he's like,
all right, you're a stupid
fucking bitch. Exactly.
Do you not like Pirelli's like,
fuck dumb bitch.
What are you a Michelin Bitch?
Fuck out of my life?
He tells his brothers showed this bitch,
she's p ones and she was like,
she didn't get it for sure.
And then his brother Bitch
fucking dump bitch. I'm bitches.
So that was, that was the test. That's the
test. Let's just say you pass the test.
I love p one 50 tires. I should
is tight. You dumb bitch.
I love that. You love that shit. Fuck
yeah, dude. You want to go to dinner?
You fucking tramps. So it's
a win. Win. Yeah. And then,
but here's the thing, he says,
let's go get something to eat.
Where do you think he's going to take you?
This is what I'm wondering.
I can tell you telling Taco too easy.
Too easy. No, because that's Kinda,
that's kind of Nice too. I
think it goes like this. Uh,
do you wanna get something to eat?
Yeah, I'm hungry. I'm not hungry.
That's it. That's it. Kick
rocks. All right guys. I'll
see you later. It's like, yeah.
Yeah, you will. Fucking
expensive. Dumb Bitch. Want to
eat food all the time? Nope.
He's got a blow. Oh
yeah, he's got a blowout.
You know where I think he might take you.
You know what?
I think he might take someone like you,
someone like you because you're
prettier than the average girl. Oh Wow.
Average girl. He probably treats
a little bit worse. Oh definitely.
But someone like you, I feel like
he would take you to a Johns,
you know the other, not Vons, but John's,
he would take you to a Johns
to the Deli Department,
let you pick out your own salmon.
I'd be like,
that's he like you build
your rest a few meets.
Maybe you're like ham and then like he's
like hands on sale. Yup. Slice to ma'am.
Two meets tops. Bitch. You're like,
can I get the Italian? He's like, yeah,
right bitch and I'll let you
get four kinds of fucking meat.
Capicola and get outta here.
Kind of Bryce not giving
her brands give was a sliced
ham sandwiches. You go out
for hand sandwiches with tab.
You don't need any bread.
Bread, get fat. No one's a fat
bitch. All right, let's roll.
So then when you're
turned on after your meal,
he's rolling out of there
and you've got to go back.
You go back to his crib
and you're down at, fuck,
are you down to fuck at this point?
I mean,
aren't you turned off from
the whole experience so far?
He's talked to you. Cool.
He's taking you to cool places.
This guy is a fucking date,
some sliced ham. You got two
hands. You got to hand sandwiches.
The sad thing is I can picture the woman
that is under him like there's a woman
broken enough please. She's like, this is
what I'm worth. This is what she is. Yeah.
This is nice. He gave me this me and yeah,
and he's only called me a bitch like six
times. I think he's just playing. Yeah,
I think he's just joking around
when he calls me a dumb bitch.
Aggressive sense of humor.
You get back to his place where
his brother is there in the room.
You walk in the room,
his is curating some of the doll work.
What's with adults though?
I'm being serious.
Why does Ted collect the doll?
That's their passion.
That's always been something that
him and his brother had been into.
I don't know if that's something
to laugh at by the way.
That's really their passion. Yeah. Some
people have like a bunch of Steeler shit.
People will collect sports memorabilia.
This is the same thing. This is their,
this is their true love
and passion investment too
because sure are worth a lot.
I mean, I liked football. Are you to mock
me? Right, right. So you get back there.
His brothers in the room,
his brothers in the room and his
brother is already disrobed. Oh,
so he expects me to do,
there's got working legs though.
Nice thick working likes this. His brother
can squat like five 50 it's insane.
No, his brother's d road because
that's how they work in the nude.
They work in the nude.
They curate in the nude.
You don't want to have
all the paint and all the,
all the bullshit all over your clothes.
But he gonna ruin of your Nice Shit.
That's why he's shirtless there. They're
curating. Yeah, they're making stuff.
They're making cool stuff.
And so his brother and he says,
would you like to disrobe and
help us with some of them?
Are you not going to get naked and help
him cure rate? You put it that way. Yeah.
I feel like that's an obvious natural
to be nude and curate because you're
trying to get it now that
you're, I get it now. Sorry.
I see it and you know what happens
at the end of the night, Tom,
do you know what happens? What
happens? They're done curating. Yeah.
He gets you a bus ticket home. He doesn't
even try to fuck you. You dumb bitch
that guys, that's really
cool why? He buys me.
But the last bus runs at nine 30 so
he's already, he's got that down,
but it's dark out.
He doesn't know the bus schedule.
He blows and he blows you or he blows off
to the stop first. You're like, he goes,
I'll get you a bus ticket home, and
you're like, oh, I think it'll be,
it's like eight 56 I'm not giving
you the money. You stupid bitch.
I'm not going to let you
spend it wherever you want.
I'm going to give you a ticket so you
make sure that you spend the money on the
ticket, right pocket
it, try to get rich off,
which does sound like something that
women have done to him in the past,
which is why he got mad. He
gave them cash. She's like,
you'll just for your bus bitch.
And they went and got something else.
Oh you go to Sephora,
you fucking bitch.
You bought some rouge bitch that
was for the bus, for the bus.
Use the money for what I fucking told
you to use it for. You know some rules.
But here's the thing, my mother
used to call on your way home.
You're on the bus. You just like
lost it in that glow of love,
that new relationship energy. And
you're just like, wow, awesome.
Do you think you're like immediately like
I got to go out with them again? What?
What's like the feeling of yes,
I am in love and I think to myself,
when's he going to text?
When's he gonna call? Right.
But he's playing the game too because
playing the long game three days before
any contact.
So it's a game of chicken where I'm like,
do I do I acknowledge that we
had a wonderful night together?
Do I wait for him? That could be a
risk though. But here's the thing,
it's 2019 and I'm a
progressive sort of gout. Okay?
I'm not afraid to reach out and let a
guy know how I feel and take initiative,
so I'm going to send that first text.
What do you think your first Texas at Ted.
She's super cash.
Hey,
she's a thanks for the bus fare home.
Super Nice meeting you and your bro.
He's big into punctuation. I'm
just letting you know that. Oh,
so I'd want to know what the big
curve balls going to be though. Matt,
his brother ends up texting you on
his own. Do you think so? Oh yeah.
Oh yeah. Yeah. Squats a lot. Well,
look at this as you're texting Ted.
Hmm. That's a new, open
it up. Yo. What's up?
Oh Shit. It's Micah. You fucking bitch.
Ted's brother Mike. It's
a biblical name. No Shit.
He talked about God and it's right there
religious. Then you have that moment.
Now I have to choose
between the two brothers.
What are you going to choose? This
is a big issue. Okay, well hold on.
Let's go through it. The merits
of both. On one hand you have ted,
it was kind of a quiet introvert.
Yeah. On one hand you've
got this cool guy, ted,
who we've discovered,
right? On the other hand,
Mike has got a cool job at the tire store.
No tires front to back.
I mean you'll never have a tire
question in your life, sir,
and your life and he's employed like the
guy with a good job. Health insurance.
You know what I mean?
To think about these things for you.
The future children 401k health insurance,
strong man lifts all day,
right? Yeah. Ted took me to
the Deli counter. He did.
Don't forget that.
I'm not forgetting it,
but I feel like this blood you
choose to meet to meet. Yeah.
You didn't just get one because mica
is known to be a guy that only lets you
have Turkey. It's true.
He's a Turkey Turkey,
but I'm saying that Micah might
take me to a sit down restaurant.
I'm talking olive garden. Really?
That's a big leap for a guy.
I don't, I think he doesn't. I think
Mike is more conscious of his finances.
I think he,
because he's making a lot of money,
he's been making a lot of
money and he sees some,
some hottie blonde he come through and
you know all your pitches like the money
dude, you think he's going to take
me? Where's Micah take you? You get,
you get cooked at home and he makes
you cook the meal for you guys.
But we'll hold on. Why don't you
come over and go over and cook,
but I can't. But then the brand
or is there you fucking making,
how am I going to cook?
How'd the brother's gonna
be there too? If I go back,
he's got to take me out cause I already
devised a plan to get Ted away from the
house.
He does this thing sometimes where he
has a buddy who has a astro van number.
The old astro vans drive him way up out
to like Simi Valley and he makes them
try to get home anyway. It's like
a game that they play. He's like,
you've got to get back to, so he's got
a couple hours to kill brotherly love.
It is there, but it's just for
fun. They're just joshing around.
But it does give him a good gap of
time. That's true. So you're there,
you're going to be alone with him.
Then he's like,
Yo come over and fucking cook dummy.
So you go over to Mike,
his house to cook.
I mean when you put it that way,
it's like is it easier to pay it?
Okay.
And then I come home there. I'm also, we
don't have pots and pans. Fucking stupid.
Bring your own shit. Some shit
on the way over here. Okay.
He doesn't have weird sense
of humor are so funny.
Oh you guys are hilarious. So you
go through all this breakdown. Who,
who is more worth it to you, Mike or
or 10 but that's okay. So like I said,
on the one hand on paper looks
better. Sure. On the other hand,
Ted's a little more secure.
There's more emotional security.
What's head? He's not going
to cheat on me. Mike has got
a lot going. Hell No. Yeah,
he won't.
You're actually right about then if I'm
a girl who was a little insecure and
beaten down,
like you know,
I might go for Ted cause like have
you watched love after lock up?
The premise is like you get somebody who
is so weak that they're never going to
leave you and that's what you want.
A 90 day fiance, the Indonesian
chick that comes over to Wisconsin,
my favorite. How about he's like, ah, I
left for a week. His plays is such a mess.
Not Darn it and it's such a fucking dump.
So sad. It's so depressing, but you,
you end up feeling so
much better than that guy.
Like I always like just want to
reach through the TV and be like,
you fucking idiot. Yeah. No, but you know
what he, a lot of those people ask for it.
A lot of those people ask for it.
They want it, they know it. Okay.
You're on a TV show called nine yet
you have to get married in 90 days to
approve someone's visa. Yeah. You're
rushing this thing you for no.
At no moment. Did you step back and go,
this seems a little contrived, right?
No moment. Well then you ask
for it. If you're that into it,
that you don't have the self awareness
to go. This is a little crazy,
like a little weird, a little crazy. If
you have none of that self awareness,
I'm cool. That's going to, I'm fine
with that girl from Jakarta, right?
She has extreme wealth like she comes
from, which is very odd, but I think,
what do you think it's to come here too.
She wants to go to medical school.
I know,
but it's got to be deeper than that to
get away from the family because medical
you can get, they can get visas to come
to. Yeah, that's what I was wondering.
There's actually use that guy.
There's gotta be something.
There's got to be something
that we don't know.
Something about like
property or real estate.
That's a big thing for people overseas
to come and buy property and real estate
or investing in something.
There's something that we
don't know that's happening.
I like how depressed she gets when she
realizes what his life really is. Like,
oh my God. Oh we all get to press.
It hits me harder than it hits her.
It's rough because she's just,
she's literally going down.
She's smart enough like to have the
analization of like how sad it really is.
Yeah. But it hits home
harder when we watch it cause
you're like, you're in this,
you're stuck in this thing.
This is like quicksand for her.
She's actually not a stupid person,
which is so weird that you're like,
it's not a trick.
She's not like being coerced or she's
not being pulled into something sad and
gross.
Yeah.
She is smart enough to use the system
but also like put herself in a worse
situation. That's why I think
something else. It's fascinating.
Something must be up to the surface.
A show on TV. We have to wrap up.
Yup. Sadly, you are always the
best. Thank you for loving you guys.
Whiskey ginger. Subscribe now.
It's a great podcast. Sorry.
Prescribed now.
Um,
you will soon be having the videos up
on Mondays here on the your mom's house
podcast channel. Excited. Oh, we'll play,
we also will have a separate
channel just for clips.
We'll do highlights of your show.
They're awesome. So that will all,
you can also subscribe to that.
Um,
is there anything else you want to add
before we wrap up? I don't have anything.
I'm a January 19 there'll be in
Bakersfield if you're up there.
Come on up here and then the next weekend
I'll be in DC or the DC metro area.
I got, I got yelled at
about that. I was in,
it's an Arlington and people are Oh yes,
not DC. I'm like, I'm sorry. I apologize.
You fucking bitch. Drafthouse house only
draft. I'll send you a draft though.
You fucking idiot. Fucking
idiot. This is getting,
I got yelled at about it.
Looks like a fart Mike by Dj Fart.
Moose is going to take us out. Alright.
Uh, thank you guys for joining us.
This first episode of the new studio
new episode thing. Oh, we love you.
We'll see you in a week. Hi Team. Jean.
We've been looking into Fort Myers,
which has been a long time
coming and people need your
heart. My heart, my heart.
Mike, too cute. Yeah. Yeah. I'm serious.
Professional mix. Yeah. I've
been looking into Fort Myers,
which has been a long time coming out to
people in the heart. My heart, my heart,
my two.
Tom,
that was a perfect, yeah,
we got the equipment part,
Mike. I felt like a lot of our listeners
are certain lenses out wanting. Correct.
Can I have the park there? Register.
Oh,
so it did all that work.
Well, these chairs, like you've said,
this Floyd are not conducive
to the parts department.
Wow.
Smells bad tears that was
proud of herself on spark. Mine
really lean over. You had a pregnant
when you laid your shit. Hammer drill.